[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
losing Warriors
oh man
your reconcileable differences in other
words he won't [__] listen to my
legal advice
this isn't complicated stuff is it is is
this really this complicated
that that you're supposed to when you
hire an attorney and you pretend that
you're going to pay him money
because that's probably what it really
is right it really is that Trump found
out that trustee went and turned on his
ass in the indictment
for the documents Casey's like all right
I'm not paying you so trustee's like all
right well I'm not going to be your
lawyer then [__] you know it's you know
it was a back and forth right 100 back
and forth whining crying bitching and
moaning
between Grandpa Poopypants the the
pretend president
and Jim trustee the ambulance chaser
like even even like a Jim trustee
is he is he that good of a lawyer really
is he or is this just the guy that would
[__] debase himself to
file these defamation lawsuits against
CNN that's the one he dropped out of
this morning now now we know that Jim
trustee is one of the attorneys in the
indictment turning one or two or some
[__] like that
he's one of them in there
and he actually bailed as soon as the
indictment became public and the reason
why is because he probably knew him and
him and Raleigh is that is that the
other [__] attorney's name who God
knows who the [__] that guy is
trustee's the one that was on TV
well one of the ones that was on TV
one of the ones that was [__] on TV
and really honestly that's that's what
this is all about for some of these
attorneys is they want to become
television news stars or whatever
to give their illegal analysis like
Jonathan Turley
hmm oh man
but trustee's out
because you can't trust him apparently
Trump can't trust him I don't know
it's really
I tell you when when you have a client a
person who is
um stuck
in this battle of criminal legal
criminal legal woes
and you can't even manage to hang on to
an attorney during that time and he's a
supposed billionaire right like this
guy's supposed to be [__] rich I mean
just [__] Rich God awful Rich which
he's not because billionaires don't beg
a bunch of [__] toothless rednecks
for five dollars right they just don't
they don't they're not like hey hand
over your mortgage to me friend I'm a
billionaire and I I need money what
I thought you were [__] rich
I I don't know it's weird but you would
think that a really rich [__] I
mean a billionaire a real legitimate one
would be able to I don't know attract
attorneys come on this should be [__]
easy like do you know do you know how
many attorneys in this country make
their entire [__] living chasing
around rich people some of them run
around chasing ambulances right like
trusty he's an ambulance chaser Alina
Haba she's not is she even really hey
can you check on Alina Abba's law
license to see if we've got the
confirmation or Christina Bob who's
never been in a [__] courtroom until
she had to go defend Trump
I mean there are attorneys in this
country not them well I mean they're
making their living off the Griff that
the billionaire the fake billionaire is
selling to his sheep right his cult
but I'm talking there's legitimate
attorneys out there
who practice law that's what they do
they just didn't go to law school they
they practice it like it's their job
and their entire living is made off of
and it's a really good living made off
of Just retainer fees for really [__]
rich people
like that's their entire [__] living
I mean there's attorneys out there that
are like public defenders and they're
like they don't get paid worth of [__]
and they're probably the smartest
attorneys right
they're probably some of the actual
smartest [__] attorneys now they're
overloaded over work they don't they
don't have enough time to defend the
cases that they have right I mean that's
the shitty part about capitalism
sometimes right I mean that's just the
shittiest part about it
is that some of the best and brightest
end up being the least paid
because you know they'll feed you full
of that line of [__] that oh if
you're really good if you're really
smart and you're really this and you're
really that you'll make you'll make the
most amount of money which isn't true I
mean look at Elon Musk he's a [__]
idiot
Silver Spoon [__] idiot
couldn't [__] work his way out of a
wet paper sack that a rock that a dick
rocket came in right but this guy
everyone thinks he's smart but he's not
but he's got all kinds of [__] money
I mean he doesn't anymore
he doesn't anymore his stupidity helped
him out with that
yeah
but some of the best and brightest
attorneys in this country are public
defenders or they they're corporate
lawyers they go and they work for
corporations
and corporations pay them pretty decent
money
to make sure that they're protected from
the almighty uh tax dollar
right
and then and then you got and then you
got the uh the one the skeezy ones right
you got the skeezy attorneys because in
in any career man you got skis right you
gotta have ski I mean [__] maybe I'm
considered skis in this career [__] I
don't know
I mean you decide you're the audience
yeah you're pretty smart Audience by the
way but here's the thing is
is that there are attorneys in this
country that make an entire [__]
living following around rich people are
people who appear to be rich or have
some sort of money
I believe Jim trustee is one of those
and I believe Jim trustee uh wants to be
wanted to be a television it's TV star
and that's what Trump promises these
these [__] idiots like Christina Bob
and uh Elena Haba uh Jim trustee
um uh Taco penis what's his name the guy
who defended and lost the case with
Eugene Carroll and it's probably gonna
lose again
um As Trump continues to defame Eugene
Carroll named taco penis right anyways
these attorneys want to be TV stars and
that's what Trump promises him right
he's like look not only are you going to
be my attorney but you're going to do it
for free because really I mean pretty
much for free you're gonna destroy your
entire [__] reputation you're gonna
look like a fool no one's gonna take you
seriously from here on out but boy
you're gonna be on the TV a lot
you're gonna be on the TV a lot there's
going to be all kinds of [__] news
stories about you it's going to be
fantastic
I mean yesterday we talked about the
non-lawyer that he has Tom
Tom I wear my little sister's shirt
fitting right
he does he wears those is his that's his
little sister's shirt that he puts on
that's why it doesn't fit
poor guy
oh poor [__] guy but Tom's not even a
lawyer Tom's not even a lawyer but you
know he's on the boob tube right he's on
the [__] traitor TV News Network all
the time
and Hell he's in Trump's ear
tell him all kinds of non-legal advice
get him indicted
on 34 counts in New York and 37 counts
in in the in the southern district of
Florida
going Tom and really honestly trusty is
part of this too trusty
trustee didn't see that Trump was trying
to help him commit crime
and then the guy has to go testify in
front of the the grand jury and has to
[__] be deposed
the attorney client privilege stripped
away from them
because they were helping him commit
crime and he has to drop out of that
case and this morning he drops out of
the CNN defamation case
he just can't represent Trump anymore do
you think you're gonna you think you're
gonna find Trump's gonna find anyone to
continue that CNN [__]
I mean it's a [__] case he ain't
gonna win it's like when he tried to
[__] Sue Twitter and Facebook you
remember this he tried to sue him that
went to the [__] quick
that went to the [__] quick
it's all nonsense
but it gives you a good roadmap of
what's going to happen here because no
matter no matter if Trump can't get an
attorney or Trump loses these cases or
his motions fail which they are bound to
do they are good he's gonna lose every
[__] motion he may win one or two
with Canon maybe one or two
but definitely not the attorney-client
privilege one the crime
exemption where he was trying to get his
attorneys to commit crime
and it's that's not gonna happen
that one's not gonna get he's not going
to get a motion to adjourn the [__] out
of here and dismiss this case come on
man
37 counts they got material evidence
built into the indictment
actual recordings Republicans they're
like real audio tapes not some [__]
that Rudy Giuliani made up some person
and now they're dead and they told the
FBI this and there's a there's a FBI
form that said they're 17 recordings and
two of them are Joe Batten talking to
barisma no they're not
you're full of [__] [__]
get give us the [__] audio you
[__]
we're gonna hear the [__] audio when
we go to trial on this the documents
case you're gonna hear the audio
eventually sometime especially
especially if he goes to trial you're
gonna see this evidence out in open
court that's what you're gonna see now
it's gonna be a little difficult because
some of this information like some of
the [__] that he was showing people it's
highly [__] classified they can't
just be showing any Tom Dick and Harry
this stuff
that's going to be some of the Motions
that are going to be weird right
because I believe that Trump and his
legal team are going to try to force the
courts to show that [__] in open public
because they they're going to want to
say well well what's so bad what's so
bad of Trump's showing it if you can
just show it to the public and it's open
and open in the open that's what they're
gonna say
mark my words [__] write it down
Friday June 16th 12 15.
p.m Tony Michael said yes eventually
Trump and his [__] stupid chaos
machine online are going to be talking
about how well why why why can you
charge him if you can just show it and
open public
just and Mark it down
as one of their stupid [__] arguments
it's gonna happen don't it you might as
well not even doubt me on that
now a lot of people um
have been commenting
um over over the um
over the year or over the last few days
that I said that Trump won't go to a
jail
I never said Trump won't go to jail I
just said he won't see trial
he won't see trial until after the
election
that's that's what it's going to be
so if if we if we get to a position
where we have trial he might see jail
now I don't know what it looks like to
lock up a former president of the United
States I mean I know what what I want it
to look like to lock up Trump right I
know you get I know you guys know what
you want it to look like
right
I mean I'd love to see him in handcuffs
in an orange jumpsuit behind a set of
bars
like
solitary confinement type [__] right
drive that [__] nuts
and what you should do I mean if we're
really thinking about this
what what it should be is like you know
just have that little slot where the
food goes through and don't give them a
whole big mac right just give him like
just a half of the bun you know what
make a Big Mac right
so it and then cut off take the top off
cut half the bun and just give him half
the that way he can smell it it's like
[__] Big Mac torture
Big Mac torture because you know this
guy isn't going to be able to keister
those things right he's not going to be
up keister to those things to get him
into prison no [__] way
no way
I don't even know if that guy can reach
his ass to wipe right
anywho but a lot of people said I was
saying that he's not going to get locked
up now I don't know what it looks like
to imprison a former prison I I don't
know we we don't know that we don't know
what a judge will decide
um when you're when you're incarcerating
a former president and and really
honestly it could be up to the federal
judge of exactly how it's done
um I believe I believe though
uh fortunately or unfortunately however
you want to look at it a federal judge
when they do sentence this idiot they're
gonna commute his sentence to like
hazarus or some [__]
yeah it's probably what it's going to be
you're probably going to be very
disappointed in this incarceration to be
Guan honest I mean just like just like
everyone's going to be disappointed and
that that they're not going to go to
trial until after the election but
that's why I keep saying we got to
engage in this process right we're his
[__] jury [__] [__] the trial down in
DC to hell with what happens in Georgia
because I think in Georgia someone said
that the other day too because I played
the clip of Tish James saying that
they're all Journey those cases
which I believe that that Bonnie Willis
will probably indict him and she'll
definitely pursue all the other people
that are indicted in those cases in
Georgia but they may adjourn the case on
him specifically waiting for the federal
cases to play out
now we'll see what kind of guts
following Willis has I mean she made
Fanning Willis may have some serious
[__] you know she may be a John Wayne
toilet paper [__] you know what
I mean rough tough don't take [__] off
nobody that's what I'm trying to say
but Bonnie Willis and she says she's
going to go ahead
now rather again rather that's just go
ahead with the indictment or go ahead
with the proceedings to trial
which I mean I I guess we'll find out I
think the most important part about what
we're going to see in Georgia is not
only not only uh uh Trump's indictment
because I I actually believe that's the
um
again that's the pop at the end of the
firework right
you know and just
but there's all the lights and all the
stuff afterwards that kind of floats
down
that's what that's what I really want to
see in Georgia is what this selector
scheme really was like what their plan
was
and then it can that be applied to
Nevada Arizona Michigan Pennsylvania
Wisconsin we know they tried it in those
places I mean [__] Michigan they were
holding one at Michigan hey wasn't
Michigan where they were holding uh
fake elector meetings like outside
or was that another state but they
another state they had a whole was it
Pennsylvania
where they had a whole nother room they
set up a [__] conference room for
this state the fake electors
to vote and [__]
to do up their own little fraudulent
little electors
those [__] people are in trouble
I mean and if they're not in trouble if
they're not a Target well they're damn
sure Witnesses
and I think the name uh Rudy Giuliani
Jenna Ellis I believe that Genie Genie
Thomas will come up for sure
damn sure John Eastman
all these names are gonna pop their
heads up I mean we watched as Rusty
Bowers the former Speaker of the House
of Arizona Republican
talk about the fake elector scheme and
how Rudy Giuliani and Jenna Ellis was
trying to sell this [__] trying to get
him
to call us a a a a special session
to overturn the election there in
Arizona in Trump's favor with no
evidence like even when Rusty Bowers
when they flew out he's like yeah come
out here
see me bring your evidence and let's do
this [__] Rusty Bowers was on board
and then when they sat down and he asked
for the [__] to show me the list
they're like yeah we don't really have a
list that's all [__] I mean
if there were a list Rusty if there were
a list it would be fantastic
and you don't think Rudy was selling
that [__] all over the rest of the
country including Georgia give me a
[__] break and this guy talking about
how oh yeah the witness but but that
half the recordings of Jill Biden that
never died where he never talked to
barisma they're dead now okay all right
you people watch too much [__] TV
you watch too many [__] movies Rudy
you people just make this [__] up what
the [__] now here's the damage that's
actually done you know we mock it and we
make fun of it we have to try to head it
off right we gotta put up the damnable
for the lies you know we gotta hit him
off but here's the thing they accomplish
what they wanted to accomplish
with this uh with this recording Joe
Biden berezma thing which isn't [__]
real by the way it's all [__] it's
all [__] and the only thing you need
to know is Republicans are the ones out
there talking about this [__] that's all
you need to know about it and it's
complete 100 utter [__] nonsense
[__]
that's all you need to know is that
they're the ones talking about it
but the thing is they accomplish what
they wanted to accomplish with this
story yeah absolutely they did
their goal
with this story
was to convince the Sheep the cult that
there is evidence that Joe Biden is more
of a criminal than Donald Trump so vote
for Donald Trump because he's not as
much of a criminal as Joe Biden
that's it
are you listening to me I don't give a
[__] about impeaching Biden they don't
care about any of that they just need to
keep their cult
with the cult leader
that's it James Comey Comer
and Jim Jordan Donald Trump Chuck
Grassley Ron Johnson Rudy Giuliani they
all cook this [__] up
they all cooked this [__] up to get him
to stay with Trump because it's not a
coincidence that Chuck Grassley went on
the floor of the United States Senate
the night before Donald Trump was
arraigned on 37 felony counts
of the Espionage Act in the southern
district of Florida that's not a [__]
coincidence
they did that on purpose
and they did it did I mean I know
there's people I know
that were reposting [__] on Facebook and
typing out Joe Biden Joe Biden
German
took a five million dollar bribe and
somehow 5 million turned into 10 million
did you ever notice that in this little
lie like they said it's 5 million and
then they're like no it's 10 million
because there's a transaction that we
don't know where it came from for 10
million dollars so it must be this
they're so full of [__] [__] but
that's a feature
it's a feature
that's not a side effect that's a
[__] feature of these fascists
the thing that they want to do is put
the [__] out in the universe
so these brain dead Maga sheep these
cult members believe this [__]
I mean they're gonna believe it at first
glance right just like that but it's not
about believing the facts it's not about
believing the story okay
it's about sticking with the cult member
this is what Jim Jones would do he'd
make up all kinds of weird [__] just
make up weird ass [__] for his cult to
believe
and it wasn't to get them to believe
this stuff necessarily it was get them
to believe that they should stick with
him right
they should stand by him he's the one oh
he's gonna protect uh they're coming
after us but he's the only one standing
in the way that sort of [__] right
it's what he's doing
and that plays into the narrative
when they say well Joe Biden he I mean
Trump may have done some stuff that's
bad okay we admit it but Joe Baden
took a bride from barisma for five maybe
10 million dollars and we got two
recordings that don't exist that you
can't hear because they never happened
because the person who said they
happened is now dead
let's make any [__] sense to you no
it doesn't to you because you got a
couple brain cells to rub together
to the people who had to who need this
confirmation bias to know that they got
to stay with their their cult leader the
orange deity
orange Mussolini Jesus Grandpa poopy
pants the Cheeto dust q and honor
they gotta stick with him they need this
narrative they can't have people peeling
off or oh Ronnie footing pudding fingers
okay
they don't want they don't want a
meatball army they want a shark army
okay
I'm so glad it's Friday it's Friday
yesterday I had a lot of fun last night
I got wasted I was dancing watching live
music yeah that's right I'm being
transparent what else do you want me to
do do you want me to lie to you like no
I'm sober I was totally sober last night
I sat and
I read a book and read poetry now
I was drinking queer beer I was drinking
Bud Light
and having a good time listening to some
music dancing my [__] legs hurt I'm
getting old goddamn I danced all night
but it's a great night I'm glad it's
Friday I'm glad you're here we have bone
end of the week
and bone of the week plays into all
these stories that we just talked about
we got some extra ones in there too with
Tommy tuber bill
Tommy Tommy two branches do you remember
when he thought that there was only two
branches of government or he could only
name two branches the governor
this is a sitting United States Center
and he doesn't know how many branches of
government we got that's [__]
fantastic well Tommy's a scumbag uh
obviously
um and so we're going to talk about that
today uh in the bonehead of the week
and we're going to talk about this Trump
Fenton thing and also I'm sure we'll get
to Rudy and Grassley we'll get we'll get
to this nonsense that we have but I I
want I want you to um go into the
weekend knowing that um they can't stop
[__] stepping on rakes like this is
and we got to point it out we got to be
loud and we've got to engage in our
democracy and one way to do that one way
to do that is to share this Show's link
sure certainly why not go watch it every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch
and live from the Facebook page don't
forget you can watch it on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels you can also see it on
the up buyers YouTube channel if you
like YouTube just go to the upr.com you
can follow their Channel there or just
type in the up wire on YouTube you'll
find it I want to thank everyone over on
Twitch the Lively chat over on Twitch
we've got a lot of new followers there
want to say welcome to all the new
followers and the new subscribers
a lot of people have linked their Prime
account their Amazon Prime account to
their Twitch account and gave us the one
free subscription they get every single
month you gotta renew it every single
month on Twitch but once you link the
two it's really easy the directions are
at
our website just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can also check out my
patreon while you're there and you can
follow all the other links you can
follow YouTube on there the link is
there you can follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod
you can also download it right directly
from there you just from Apple Spotify
Google but you can go to the Tony
michaels.com and you find all those
links there
oh we got a great uh bone head today
and I got some clips maybe we'll shoot
this [__] too since it's Friday so don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show it's Friday
bonehead of the week
you vote you decide who is the bone net
of the week me and my goals eats inches
break it down in the second hour
I mean we know who the bonehead is right
he won last week sure he won this week
everyone says they love the boycott
binder you like that uh you like that
one uh next week maybe we'll put the uh
the new commercial the trumpet hole in
the uh in the rotation
oh and he's got some new commercials
coming too so don't don't go anywhere
don't change that dial
you have more and more and more great
commercials Gabe Sanchez got a
commercial here up his ass didn't he he
just like commercial commercial
you just pound them out now bam bam bam
all new commercials so you're not going
to want to miss a thing so make sure to
subscribe right here on YouTube
You're Not Gonna Want to Miss a single
thing or on Twitch as digital waterfall
over there says love the boycott binder
yeah let's do uh let's do a round of ask
uh excuse me shoot the [__] shoot the
[__] is kind of like ask me anything so
here's what asked me anything is ask me
anything's on my patreon page so I do
like 30 minutes it usually ends up being
like 35 or 40 because you know I talk I
don't know it's a thing it I it's a
[__] thing I got I I don't know how
to avoid it
but it's 30 minutes and you get to ask
me anything you want I'll answer any
question within that 30 minutes right
shoot the shit's a little different
where I get to pick and choose the
questions on ask me anything you guys
can ask me anything you know I'll answer
now what's for dinner today uh storm
Virgil said what's for dinner I I really
don't know what's for dinner today I I
already ate breakfast but I I normally
um I normally have the same breakfast
it's a breakfast sausage it's turkey
normally turkey breakfast sausage a
couple eggs
uh uh a cinnamon raisin bagel with the
strawberry cream cheese that's right and
maybe some yogurt
let me show you what I have in the
morning with some coffee of course you
gotta [__] have coffee like I can't
do anything without at least having like
two or three
coffee's in me I gotta have coffee like
what the hell what the hell else how
else are you gonna read the news and put
up with this [__] oh hey Tony can you
get some [__] Pride uh stickers yeah
we can put some [__] pride stickers
you want the stickers yeah well I'll
make some stickers today I'll make some
stickers today and then um you guys uh
watch out hate mods can you remind me
I'm aware about this listen I'm really
good at talking I'm horrible at
remembering things to do [__] I'm I just
I'm a good host but um I'm not the um
the greatest when it comes to
remembering everything so in my mind to
keep me on track they really do
um for whatever reason on Thursday
there's always this bonehead of the week
alert they're like hey last alert last
alert last alert
bonehead of the week where is it so me
and Gabe are like oh yeah the bone of
the week of course last night I was um I
was probably three beers deep and I was
listen to live music when it was going
on so
[Laughter]
ah good thanks thanks for reminding me
okay what else do we have I ever been in
a physical fight oh yeah it's been a
long time but yeah oh yeah a lot of them
when especially when I was younger
because when I grew up
um I grew up with the five other cousins
and they were all boys
and we would always be fighting like
always and we're all around the same age
you know so yeah we got a lot of fights
when I was a kid but that it's where I
come from you know
and you do that do I have any weekend
plans
um yes I have a birthday party a kid's
birthday party that I'm going to so that
should be fun
no it'd be fun it'll be fun it'll be fun
what's the name uh
of that music that plays
on my insta I I don't know which which
one
which one are you talking about
the name of the music
which video I'm not real sure
coffee yuck yes coffee
um
and Tony asked
what's for dinner on Friday Jagermeister
could be could be don't you can't don't
you might yep
um Tony B Tony TB asks what Secrets did
Don sell and to who I think you're
talking about Donald Trump who did he
sell them to you know I I don't know if
he was selling them or if he was
um
promising the information
and he couldn't remember the information
that's why he had to steal it so he had
it because then I don't think he's
actually going to hand the [__] over
thank you
I can believe that Donald Trump was
going to hand it over like someone like
the Saudis
he'd have to believe that he would
eventually hand it over to the
government right like you would assume
that he just like [__] you know take
that copy machine that was in that
storage room to start making copies and
then hand over the originals and then
take the copies and you know sell them
to whoever but I don't think it was
about like handing over the actual
information I think it was about because
he's a [__] idiot he can't remember
all this [__] we know that they weren't
giving him real presidential briefings
because the guy couldn't [__] retain
this [__] and not not only could he not
retain it but he couldn't understand why
they were even collecting this stuff he
didn't even really understand what went
into collecting information that he's
being indicted for like and he was
president of [__] the United States
highest on the totem four Poll for
classified information
and he still doesn't understand it still
to this day even when he's out there
yeah yelling and screaming whining and
bitching about it he doesn't understand
what went into it and why it's [__]
dangerous
for him to be [__] not only showing it
to people but declassifying it he's like
odds I'm just I Declassified it I
Declassified it [__] man that's just as
dangerous as showing it to somebody why
would you declassify something that's
going to put people in danger that's the
whole point of the classification system
in the first place is to make sure this
information doesn't get out into the
public
so that doesn't put people's lives in
danger you [__] idiot
again trying to explain this to these
[__] boneheads is worthless
um
someone asked a boss man Texas asked
Tony should Fox News allowed be allowed
to broadcast on Military races I mean
there's TVs there they're on a cable
station what are you gonna do
um you know you turn you can turn on the
Cartoon Network and turn it on lifetime
you turn on Fox news right
you know I mean I mean it's not about
listen listen folks
you can't you can't
get rid of Fox News right that's not
gonna help just because you get rid of
Fox News doesn't mean these people
aren't gonna go search out their
confirmation bias
that's not that's not the problem the
problem isn't Fox News
the problem is is that people want
to be lied to about this stuff that's
the real that's the root of the problem
in this country
Fox News is just a [__] symptom of it
Donald Trump is just a symptom of it
this white Christian nationalism is
really the heart and the root of the
problem right white supremacy is the
root of the problem
and for you know several times in our
history white supremacy has reared its
ugly head in this country
fascism is reared its ugly head in this
country
but we're at a point now where it's the
white Christian nationalists and they're
they're using the apparatus of American
Christianity
to impose their fascism on us and use
legislation by getting getting their
[__] Nazis elected
whether it be County local state or
federal government
and pushing their [__] agenda on us
yes that's what they're doing to us
this whole oh you're sticking you're
sticking your pride your gayness in our
face shut the [__] up man just because
you're terrified of rainbows at Target
doesn't mean any anyone's jamming
anything down your throat no one's going
around knocking on your door
trying to force you to be gay there's a
hell of a lot of people running around
this country knocking on doors trying to
get you to be Christian and jamming
Christianity white Christian nationalism
and white supremacy down your [__]
throat
and there's good examples of
Christianity in this country but they're
few and far between anymore that's why
it's so hard not to [__] just put
them all in one category the one of the
examples I don't know if you're paying
attention one of the examples is the
United Methodist Church and some folks
in the audience may be members of the
United Methodist Church here in this
country and United met in United United
Methodist Church about 250 churches have
peeled off
because they don't want openly gay
people working for the church now some
of them are like well we'll let them
we'll let them be
will let them be parishioners here but
we're not going to let them be part of
the staff we're not going to hire any of
them gays
250 of them
but there's a shitload of United
Methodist Church churches out there
they're like no we we will hire them you
goddamn right will hire them they're
people just like us just because they
love someone different than you doesn't
make it any more sexual than your
[__] relationship why do they do that
why what in the [__] hell makes a a a
homosexual relationship more sexual than
a heterosexual one
just because you can't get the the idea
of two people of the same sex having sex
out of your mind doesn't make it more
sexual for them or anyone else that's a
you problem if the first thing that
comes to your mind when you see a gay
person or talk to a gay person or even
think about a gay person the only thing
you think about is sex well that that's
a that's a you thing that's a you think
Matt Walsh that's a you think Ben
Shapiro
that's it you think Michael Knowles
that's it you think Benny Johnson
you [__] bigots
it's a you thing
so back to the Fox News on Military
basis you're not gonna stop it
you're not going to stop a Fox News
you're not going to stop it from
existing inside our our [__] country
where you have the freedom and liberty
to have a [__] conservative news
station
the problem is is that a conservative
conservative a white supremacy a white
Christian nationalist news organization
quote unquote I'll be John Jr here news
organization
it exists because it's marketable to
these [__] bigots
the bigotry's the problem
that's the heart that's the root of it
it's the fascism I mean why do you think
we're in such a bad state
we just need we just need better media
is what we need that's what we need we
need better media and someone says yes
tax the churches [__] yeah tax the
churches that'll help too
tax those [__] everyone's
saying taxi churches to be quite honest
in there
who
uh but yeah if you if you want to do
some research uh and I'll and you want
to see uh the difference of in
Christianity and again I'm an atheist
but if you want to see
um some of the split in the divide and
what some Churches in this country
recognize as bigotry and they know it's
bigotry and they know they're turning
away people who could who could have
faith in in Christ and God and be a
Christian if that's what they choose to
do that's their Liberty that's what you
want to do you should do it if you want
to have faith by God have faith
in whatever God you want I don't give a
damn that's your Liberty
but there's churches in this country and
the United Methodist is is one of them a
certain portion of them realize that
there should be Equity there should be
equality
and it is what Jesus would do
is celebrate pride month that's what we
should do hey who wants that in emerge
store a pride crucifix
oh boy when that [__] all over him oh
God damn uh
um um Stacy asked what school did I
graduate from well I graduated from high
school uh down by the Lake of the Ozarks
I'm from I'm from the Lake of the Ozarks
here you know the Netflix series Ozarks
oh arzark Ozark
uh that's kind of the area and then I'm
from yeah that's
probably what's wrong with me
um but then I dropped that at College
twice so I'm a two-time College Dropout
I'm not ashamed to say it
I I actually believe that gives me
um the ability to speak and to folks
normal average day folks because most
people most people go to college and
they don't finish it a lot of people do
that a lot of people start families like
I did when I was young I mean I I have I
have a son that's gonna graduate from
high school next year
yeah that's right
mm-hmm
I'm I'm older than maybe what you think
I am and I may be younger than what you
think I don't know I don't know how old
you think I am
but I'm a two-time guy with drive-by and
I believe that is what gives me the
ability uh to to talk to an audience
like you guys this isn't this isn't the
[__] Coastal elitist that everyone
wants to make this out to be and that's
that's why that's why yesterday we were
beating on pod Saves America
and pod sees America again they're
political elitist
and and there's nothing wrong with that
it just
it they don't they don't [__] appeal
to normal average day Americans they
just don't Democrats have that problem
right Democrats have a huge problem with
appearing to be elitist
because they have a lot they have all
the intellectuals in their party right
intellectualism kind of breeds this
elitism type you know taste to it
and that's why I don't I don't I don't
bring out facts and data and polls and
all that kind of [__] I don't pile that
on you
you don't need to know all that [__]
to have a good understanding of the
facts and a good understanding of what's
real and what's not
and I'm trying to present that to the
show that you don't have to have some
sort of [__] law degree from Harvard
or you have to be an intellectual and
read every single New York Times and
Washington Post article
you know how many New York Times
articles I read in full are post
articles I read in full not heart not
hardly any of them that's right
that's right
do you know how much [__] cable news
I watch
most of it is in clips
of Republicans saying dumb [__] [__]
that's the most that I watch of cable
news
I understand the government I studied
government when I was when I was a
two-time College Dropout
I was studying history and I was I was
studying political science
and I've been interested in in politics
Federal politics ever since I was about
14. I would watch I would stay up at
night and I would watch uh after the
local news Ted koppa would come on
remember Nightline
and then uh I believe it was uh Bill
Mars Politically Incorrect this was
before Bill Maher went to hboe it lost
his show after 9 11. because he said
some crazy things
um and they took him off the air
politically Politically Incorrect
Politically Incorrect was it was a great
show
it it really it really did you could see
that liberalism was not the crazy
it was conservatism which is fascism
like thin veiled with this Republican
[__] right you could see it right
out in the open
on Bill Maher's Politically Incorrect
and you could watch them banter back and
forth and argue about this stuff
and most the time it was political
Talking Heads or actors or comedians
um and I remember one show uh a couple
of them um uh George Carlin George
Carlin was that's how I got introduced
to George Carlin then I started watching
his specials on HBO
but Larry Flint was on uh Bill Moore's
political incorrect too which was
amazing to watch Larry Flynn a guy who's
who does who has porno mags right he's
up he's up
he's a porno Empire and this guy could
go on this guy Larry flank could go on
Bill Marsh political Incorrect and he
could [__] squash all these
conservatives
right and they thought he was the
[__] demon
ah Larry Flint's a [__] demon right
I mean you guys might have seen the
movie with Woody Harrelson playing uh
Larry Flint the people versus Larry
Flint
and it's it's probably you know you know
hyped up in Hollywood up from from the
original story
but if you know anything about Larry
Flynt the guy's [__] brilliant
he's brilliant
but the way he would banter back and
forth and argue it it really gave me the
sense even way back when I mean we're
talking 20 years ago
over 20 years ago really it gave me a
sense way back when that it you don't
have to be uh part of the political
apparatus to have a political opinion
you don't have to be part of the
political apparatus to have an opinion
on social issues nor do you have to be
the most educated
and have the most degrees and the best
pedigree
to sit and talk about political issues
and make a good point and to drive a
good point home you don't you don't have
to
you don't I don't
but the elitists think they do
right
and the most Elites are on the right
right they're the ones that are telling
you what you can and can't [__] do
right Josh Hawley saying are you to be a
man you have to you have to do this and
you have to do that you have to read the
Bible and we'll get the [__] out of here
you don't have to read the Bible
to be a good man
to be a good dad to be a good brother to
be a good husband you don't have to read
the Bible it might help I you know I
don't know there's probably some stuff
in there that makes it good there's
probably some [__] in there to make you
a horrible man
just saying God wasn't always good read
the front part of that book
anyways
the point is is that
yes
I did drop out of college twice but I
think it gives me the ability to talk to
folks with folks not at them not over
them not to them talk with them that's
what I enjoy about this show more than
anything is and and because the audience
is getting bigger and bigger it's hard
to catch every single comment it really
is
um but you're the greatest audience in
the world we love engaging with you
rather you come here to love to watch us
or you come here because you love to
hate us we we don't mind we don't care
we want everyone to come to the show
because we actually believe that there
is no one else in the political in the
political Arena doing a show like this
none not with this tone not not with
this kind of content they're just not
they're all stuffy especially on the
left they're all [__] stuffy or
they're on the right they're just mired
in the qmi Q Anon conspiracy theories
now I'm starting to sound like Alex
Jones that was stupid friends there's
demons at the doorstep and they're
coming to get you that kind of [__]
right
but that sensationalism is what keeps
you listening it's what makes you want
to go hey have you ever heard of this
Tony Michaels guy he's [__] nuts this
guy's crazy he says the [__] I like to
hear but he's [__] nuts this guy will
say some crazy [__] and you never know
what the hell he's gonna talk about and
he never shuts the [__] up he doesn't
stop talking like there's not one pause
in this show for the entire two hours
hopefully three hours eventually so
Stacy I appreciate the question I hope
that Aunt answered it
that's a long answer wasn't it God damn
okay let's uh see if we can go to
another question here
[Music]
I think everyone stop asking questions
[Laughter]
ah yeah yeah Miss lovesick she says Jim
trusty yeah quit yeah on that was the
lead into our show Jim trustee's out on
everything that's because Trump doesn't
want him and I I wouldn't you love to be
the fly on Mike Pence's head when Jim
trusty and Donald Trump
or yelling screaming each other about
this and then Jim trust is like [__] you
then I'm out I'm not gonna do this
anymore
and I almost bet that part of it is that
he's not gonna get paid Trump's like oh
you're gonna tell on me to the feds well
I'm not paying you
I'm not paying you that's that might be
maybe what it is
let's see
um ditra says I never liked Bill Maher
but I love Carlin see Bill Maher at one
point
um he wasn't he see at one point Bill
Maher didn't have like tons and piles of
money okay Bill Maher has enough money
now he can be who he wants to be and you
know he he gets all caught up in this oh
You're Gonna Cancel me thing and he's
doing it on purpose like a lot of these
people play this cancel culture thing on
purpose right
like they're like I'll just say this
[__] so everyone [__] hates me and
then they'll [__] spread my [__]
around and it'll get us big numbers
on social media because that's what
social media is anymore it's an outrage
machine right
you just post certain clips and you got
to Trend a couple times you're saying
something crazy
right something obnoxious like tomorrow
if I just switch to be a right winger
tomorrow oh my God I would [__] be
trending everywhere
if I just said you know what [__] this
[__] [__] this liberalism [__] just went
balls deep into Q Anon and started
saying crazy [__] like Jimmy Dore did no
one who knew how the [__] Jimmy door was
right no one knew who the [__] he was he
ain't that funny anyways right
but he turned into this anti-backs right
[__] Winger who supports Trump and
boom
boom guys everywhere and the reason why
is because it's it's [__] fake Bill
Martin's the same way Bill Martin's the
same way he used to be a liberal Warrior
and hey I didn't always agree with
everything that Bill Maher said but Bill
Maher had a pretty good foundation of
liberalism right
uh in a new age style liberalism not not
old liberalism
but he but he had he had a good idea for
Liberty right and you know he was he was
Pro pro-legal legalizing marijuana just
thought it was ridiculous he thought
it's ridiculous to to Shield people from
porn or anything like that because of
religion obviously he's an atheist
um he put out the uh the movie religious
which is a good movie
rather you or either you're believer or
not it's a good movie to get you
thinking
but he had some good points right right
now Carlin on the other hand was a
comedian
um I I've read almost all of Carlin's
books which is the majority of his bits
in his show
um but Carlin uh considered himself
later on in his career a performer of
his writing so he was a writer and then
he would go perform them
um which we all know Carlin in the 80s
and the 90s was one of the greatest
Carlin errors of all time because Carlin
really had like three different well
really four different careers in comedy
but that late 80s early 90s was the one
that I paid attention to and that maybe
where might liberalism and my loud mouth
and my cursing comes from to be quite
honest that may be a lot of my
influences is George Garland because I
watched his comedy specials over and
over and over and over and over again so
Deidra thank you for the comment anyone
else got a question yeah everyone loves
George
um
is is trustee gonna be a host uh on CNN
now since he isn't representing no he's
he's gonna be a contributor somewhere
and again that's the point I was trying
to make earlier Beth is that all this
all this [__] how they how Trump Pays
His attorneys it's just like I'm Gonna
Make You Famous because it just says
Trump's attorney so you'll be famous
because I'm famous
and you'll give the shittiest legal
takes ever and on my behalf on the TV
like and he for he spoon feeds them this
[__] to go on TV and say right you know
he's on the phone with him before
they're doing the interview right he's
on the phone with him telling them what
to say then they go on and say it and
he's watching it while they're saying it
and then he calls him afterwards to tell
him how they did yeah he did great or
you [__] that up
you know that's what it is
100 you know that's what it is salty
Sylvester said Carlin is the goat he is
that I I mean Richard Pryor is probably
a really close second Eddie Murphy
coming up in the third probably behind
him
the three of the greatest comedians of
all time and Eddie Murphy's stand-up
career was very short right in
comparison to how long his career has
been but hey Murphy Oh my God Eddie
Murphy Raw are you kidding me one of the
best
one of the best
stand-up Specialist of all turn
Eddie Murphy Raw and there's a lot of
homophobia in that thing but it's it's
it's it's one of the greatest ones of
all time but Carlin is probably number
one and and the reason why is because
Carlin
um Carlin's career again he had like
four different careers Carlin had to
recreate himself every single time and
he was successful
to some degree and he was the best
and each each time each era of Carlin
you know each time you had to reinvent
himself so
very cool
I'm glad we got Carl and Vance uh in the
in the chat I went uh
when Roe when they overturned Roe last
year I clipped out the part of uh
Carlin's
one of his specials
about abortion and how the right wing
really didn't give a [__] about abortion
right
um it's about hating women they're not
pro-life they're anti-woman it's kind of
the aim of the bit right because Carlin
understood that Carlin understood what
Carlin understood the most about comedy
which like Bill Maher and some of these
other [__] idiots Dave Chappelle
um and Dave Chappelle is one of the he's
probably in top five
but what they don't understand is is
that you can't use comedy to punch down
right you can't use the punch down you
have to punch up right if you punch up
comedy actually has the effect
of getting people
to to think about it you punch down it's
just it's kind of shitty right
just a real loose stick
it's harder to punch up it's harder to
speak truth to power especially when
you're using comedy to do that so
that's why Carlin uh still resonates
today like they're saying over on Twitch
what else do you got another question
we're gonna go to a break here soon
we're going to get to Gabe Sanchez let
me see if he's let me see if that
whoever that is with the last name
Sanchez is is ready did you guys see the
remix yesterday oh my God you got to go
spread that around the Internet by the
way
the remix I think is better than the
original small rat I don't know if
anyone I I think it's better
did you guys catch it at the end of the
show yesterday yeah that's right I put
an Easter egg at the end of the credits
again we played small rats remix of
whoever that is with the last name
Sanchez
yeah it's on there
you guys should go check it out
yeah I put it on there
I waited a long time too to see if
anyone would stick around because we
played it during the show
and I waited around for a while to see
if you guys would wait
to see if that song would come in at the
very end you you didn't disappoint you
didn't disappointed let's see if he's
ready let's see if he's ready for a
bonehead of the week everyone uh stick
around we're gonna be right back I'm
gonna go to a break when we come back
we'll see if we can get Gabe Sanchez on
here Dave Sanchez
and we'll do bonehead of the week for
you don't go anywhere I'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around we're going to do
bonehead of the week I promised I
promise I promise
oh hey looky there
lucky who's in The Green Room should I
bring him into the broadcast or should I
make him wait
I'm just kidding we gotta bring that
whoever that is with the last name
Sanchez
[Music]
yes that'll never get old you know that
no it won't it won't you are huge today
why are you so big oh because here hold
on hold on are you really close to the
camera oh okay I'm not that close oh
okay yeah no I'm I'm rearranging the
you're huge today why is your head so
huge
uh no the reason is because uh I'm I'm
shifting
um
the layout of the room oh [__] where I
film this guy this guy okay so I've
switched I've switched my the [__]
behind me yeah but you have a separate
you have a separate office space all
right all right all right
that may be fair that maybe so I'm going
to Grandma's bedroom don't lie to them
yeah I know at one point it was my
grandma's bedroom what the first when
the first time that game came on the
Ruckus he had this dresser behind him
and had like a doily on it right and I
was like it was like a little it was a
club if I do what the what the [__] are
you in your grandma's bedroom yeah
there's nothing wrong with doilies
doilies or yeah they're great dude if
you're from the 1930s right right right
right right
I'm re-arranging
um because we're moving stuff around and
uh
I'm I'm currently experimenting with a
different
background
for what was that ah I see yeah yeah so
this is
yeah yeah but I think I'm I'm removing
the green screen I'm uh this
morning you're not doing the green
screen anymore I think I'm gonna go with
more of a practical background man I
might like use I might use the lights
to make the make the wall like color you
know well you know you did do a few of
those from the car now I do have to ask
because Rudy's gonna be on our list
today okay we're gonna talk about Rudy
Giuliani and one of the we played the
clip yesterday where he's in the [__]
car right yeah yeah he's in the car and
he's like yeah the person that doesn't
have the recordings that are lies that
we're talking about they're dead by the
way you'll never you'll never know now
like what the [__] he was in the car
when he was giving that interview so I
was like oh Gabe if he doesn't what was
that on this he's got to do it from the
car because Rudy did yeah so here's the
thing like I was I've experimented with
a few because I'm like like the effects
of the show in terms of like doing the
green screen this and that like it adds
more to the show when it it slows down
the process because remember it's I'm
the one doing everything behind the
scenes oh you ain't got a whole team of
people to help you yeah no I wish I had
a whole team of writers and editors hey
why don't you guys make sure wow you
have a whole team over there make sure
are you next time Gabe does what was
that you guys help him out a little bit
oh that'd be great yeah if you wanna
there's a whole [__] team I'm out
I'll make sure to I'll make sure to buy
their there's a whole [__] team taken
yeah I I do I do speaking of teamwork I
do want to think and and you guys know
who you are out there people who are
helping uh tweet who are helping write
descriptions now uh all the moderators
that come in the chat every day because
there's more and more people to moderate
in the chat but you guys not only you
keep the trolls at Bay and make sure
they're they're behaving but you also
engage in chat and it's great it's it's
the thing that we want we want this to
be you know not a piece of content that
you just come watch I mean you can do
that and share around but we want you to
be engaged in it right that's what we
want we want the audience to engage so a
bonehead of the week's about it's about
engagement that that was Gabe's original
idea was engagement speaking of content
engage with this content bro oh man so
I'm kind of you know what I'm kind of
sad to hear that the green screen
it's not to say that the green screen
won't be used for bits right yeah like I
might do you've got to do commercials
see I was telling the audience that
you're on like this commercial kick all
of a sudden I know I know I want it well
the thing is like at this wild
commercial hair up your ass and you're
running with it I know I was like I
gotta do these things super timely you
know and then I gotta switch over back
into what was that so there's a few
episodes that I'm working on that I'm
going to be writing and pumping out
but I was like I got these ideas for
these commercials and the sketches and I
haven't done those in a while so
I gotta bring it back
um but yeah so the reason that I was so
close is because I was lit I I was
editing the layout of the room
and also testing out where I could be
doing the new
um iteration we'll say of of what was
that you know got to keep it fresh got
to change it up but I figure I'll put
some color lights on the background
maybe I'll put some stuff on the wall
who knows oh yeah what are you gonna put
on the wall
I don't know a bookshelf you know I got
my bookshelf back here yeah everyone I
gotta have one of those like I'll have
like floating bookshelf look at that
dick look at that dick shadow look at
that bush gotta trim that soon man
I got this and I got a [__] closet
door back there and I got a hallway door
over there what I need what's in the
closet everyone wants to know what's in
your closet what's in the closet yeah
I can't give away
trademark Family secret I can't tell you
what's back come on man yeah I'm just
saying dude but what I'm I'm trying to
think of something I can put back here
so I'm thinking of doing some maybe some
like
floating bookshelf kind of thing maybe
back here you know yeah I don't know
over here that used to that that it's
over here you that used to be my bet
because I I switched my desk around I
got a longer disc and I got like a
command center now so that I can see
that that way the whole team right so
you guys can work out I mean you got to
have plenty of room for people to sit
down oh yeah right we got a lounge over
here there's a [__] car some people
can only Searchlight huh
Gabe definitely has a blow up doll Gabe
has a blow up down there now hold on
in there oh you do you actually you have
a skeleton I literally have a skeleton
in my closet now is it a real one or is
it just like a Halloween it's a it's
like a a prop okay well that's kind of
disappointing yeah yeah well you know I
bought it for I forgot I think I bought
it for oh you know what I bought it when
I made the droop commercial really with
uh with Molly yeah yeah yeah and well we
haven't played the droop commercial in a
long time yeah well it's not so relevant
anymore because like nobody wears masks
you know well because there's a certain
president who ended the pandemic that is
true that is true but yeah so there's a
there's a skeleton in there and I'm like
I'll use it for something else like it's
got the whole body and the arms and
stuff and I mainly just used it for the
head
uh but what else I got there I got
costumes in there I got camera equipment
in there I got board games in there yeah
you know it's a whole fun but the closet
is so small you know it's right closet
you can't fit a lot of secrets in that
small the closet is that why you have a
small closet so you can't stuff a lot of
secrets in there yeah I mean also it's
like I wouldn't even have any room for
like classified documents if I wanted to
put those in there you know well yeah
you keep those in the bathroom man yeah
no no they're they're reading material
and also if like we run out of toilet
paper
you know you keep that [__] there's a
bathroom
speaking of that here's a video from
good liars this is hilarious you've
retweeted this yesterday that's how I
saw it good lighter said this video this
is [__] hilarious watch this video
speaking of speaking of documents in the
bathroom and it's sounding really
ridiculous and stupid let's watch this
Still rocking that 2020 flag that's
weird man this is weird stuff with the
it's uh it well just watch let's say you
are Donald Trump and you know that
they're after you You're Gonna Keep the
papers in the bathroom
so what are you saying about the the
photograph so what about the photographs
that's the stage
it's stupid
for a person that knows that it's been
you know investigated it's been watching
I agree with you it's stupid stupid
stupid
why the bathroom so you can you can you
can see that they're all eyes
well there I it's stupid I agree that
it's stupid I'm just not sure it's a lie
they always run head first into it don't
they yeah also I want to ask and I'm not
I'm not trying to
why do they always seem to have these
these Eastern European or Russian
accents these um do you notice that I
don't know man you notice that is that
is
a t-shirt rather be Russian than
Democrat or something like that is it
just me are are do these I mean did you
see the clip of that woman that was
crying yes and she was like oh what
they're doing today and she had an
accent and I was like and I don't I
don't know exactly what accent that I
yeah because a lot of people ask me
about my accent they're like where the
[__] are you from yeah right because I I
not Russia I'm not not Russia buddy I
could give a damn tell you that but
here's the thing is that there's a lot
of ones that they interview that have
these weird actors there was a there was
another woman on August 8th 2022 I come
back I was out of town I came back so
like all this Whirlwind of like oh [__]
you know Donald Trump you know documents
all stuff I came home was picking up
dinner because we're like oh you know
what we don't I'm not in the mood we're
just gonna wait wait I'm sorry I know
I'm gonna step on your story here but I
gotta I just saw this we were talking
about the closet earlier I know we're
jumping back but I can't get fake gate
might be in that closet I don't know
that's possible I don't know I can you
know what if you want I can take a break
or for a moment I can go check no no Mom
go ahead go ahead with your story all
right maybe you should do a piece of
content and uh things in Gabe Sanchez's
closet oh boy that'd be like a whole
that'd be like a 10 part series well I
could be um so we I went to go pick up
food for for dinner and uh I was
following Along on on uh on I think it
was on Twitter or somewhere else but I
was watching a live feed oh it was like
it was a live feed video on Twitter of
people at Mar-A-Lago that were outside
people were like oh what the [__] are
you guys doing out here like leave leave
and they have all these mag supporters
who were there and there was the woman
with a huge [__] like foam hat it's
so big
it's comical like it looks like it's a
it is
it is supposed to be a joke right it's
like a foam finger above your head right
and it says like make America great
again and this woman had an accent and
she was like oh yeah you know I'm here
and what they're doing to Donald Trump
is unfavorable and I was like
why is it always why is it always these
people that sound like they're from like
the Eastern Bloc of Europe or like
Russia like where they come from
they got their talking points and they
just keep repeating the same thing about
how Donald Trump is a victim he's being
politically persecuted it's a it's the
weaponization of the federal government
the doj the FBI it's a deep state
but at the same time I can't take this
person seriously because they have a
huge [__] foam hat on and it's real
it's real that's not satire that is a
real heavy yeah let me see if I looked
it up we looked it up live on here let
me see if I can find that I remember I
remember this clip actually because it
was like it was at night time when when
she when they shot it the clip that
you're talking about and it's out um in
front of Mar-A-Lago and yeah and this is
the and I'm sure if I look for the clip
I could find it this is the just so
people know what I'm talking about this
is the hat that uh
that she was wearing okay oh again not a
not a joke 100 serious this is not the
woman but this is the this is the Hat
this is the hat that not only did she
wear
but other people wear at uh at rallies
that he goes to and they wear this hat
not as a joke but as a serious thing as
support for Donald Trump
uh yeah there's such [__] boneheads
uh how do we get here like this man I'm
telling you man it's insane like again
you know people you know I saw I saw a
comment uh a person I think it's a funny
hat like we were talking about like this
has got to be fake when when we saw like
there's no way it's not there's like I
fell for it
yeah no it's they're real it's all real
now the thing is like I even saw
comments on the video that I released
the other day which was for the trumpet
all right and in there a bunch of like
oh this is fun this is hilarious out of
all this stuff right and there's
somebody that came in that was uh by the
name of lucid and you'll find it because
I'm pretty sure it's like the first
comment in in the post that I tweeted
and this was like oh this is even this
is what the left always stick is funny
and I'm like look man
it's hard because
I get to a point where I make this
content and then you guys do something
and it's the truth and so I can't make
fun of you anymore so I have to so your
reality my joke becomes your reality
within moments like it becomes outdated
what was the one thing you you were
making one and I think it was when they
were drinking pee yeah it was it was the
it was like you were texting me like oh
I'm gonna have him drink pee I'm like no
no you can't have him drink pee they're
doing that now like you gotta you gotta
you gotta go one more step further like
you gotta and then you ended up making a
fake turd yeah I made a fake turd it was
crazy I mean I filmed it in multiple
locations I filmed it in a at a park
right it's like kind of in like a Ridge
Mountain Area the commitment of this guy
with the last names
and quick quick backstory in this I went
into this woodsy area because like oh
you know what this guy's gonna be out in
like outdoors and he's gonna [__] do
this spiel about how he figured out the
cure for coven he has to eat his own
[__] so I had
different types of chocolate you know
nutty chocolate milk chocolate dark
chocolate mix it all together right to
make is there anything with corn in
there was there anyway
maybe candy corn okay and so then I was
like all right so I went into this uh
this woodsy area and I had [__]
coyotes all around me I was like nope
I'm out I gotta go I'm out oh God damn
and then I just did it in my in my
bathroom now this is but that's the [__]
man it's just like you know that you
cannot you cannot I mean you can make
fun of them I'm going to continue to
make fun of them but it's they get upset
at it because it hits real close to home
well right but here's the thing this is
what I was talking about earlier about
this audio tape story yeah is that their
whole purpose of saying this [__] and
trucker Ashley saying it on the floor of
the Senate the night before Donald Trump
is arraigned and then yesterday
right is is to get people to believe
to get people to believe that this is
true before it even gets [__] smoked
out right which is smoked out really
quickly
um there's a couple good clips of Dana
Goldman absolutely [__] dunking this
[__] in the trash but here's the effect
that it has right
um now
this is a couple Trump supporters
talking to someone who's trying to talk
sense to him but listen this because the
design the design of the The Joe Budden
recording story is not to get people to
believe that there's recordings of Joe
Biden that's not it the aim in the
direction The Narrative is is that yes
Trump is a criminal but Biden is more of
a criminal right yeah yeah so like our
guy might be bad but your guys worse way
worse and our guy is the lesser of the
two criminals right that's the whole
point and here's here's a good example
of this do you love this country our
country is being destroyed on purpose by
someone who's a closet what does that
mean if he committed that means we're on
the edge of Civil War so we better get
this country right on track okay Gabe do
you have any Communists in your closet
he said there's a there's a closet I
have I have I have a skeleton in my
class but no communist no communist okay
well I'm just checking this guy says
there's closeted Communists I just want
to make sure I mean I do have I actually
I have a second closet over here right
on the other side there might be so like
I could check that later on okay I think
it's just like there's any like a shirts
and like no no con no Communists though
no no commies that I know okay well
maybe you'll check later yeah yeah
because we're being destroyed sorry
about that why do you think we're on the
brick of Civil War because our economy
is being driven into the dirt we have no
energy Independence the borders were
open we are being destroyed on purpose
by globalist forces that have control
Joe Biden China control show Biden for
an interest control him the 10 20 the
1031 just came out today 10 31 did you
hear that there's not only a 10 23 but a
10 31 I don't know what the 10 30. I
don't know I don't know what's going on
also like I love when they're like we're
energy independent we've never been
energy independent now ever we are
resources we never will be we never will
be we are dependent keyword there guys
dependent not independent dependent on
other countries to import oil and other
Goods that we use for energy okay this
idea that we had energy Independence
under Trump no we didn't we had we had
secure borders under Trump no we didn't
we had this under Trump no we didn't
right everything they said like oh we
had low unemployment oh are you sure
about that because that should Spike
real high during covet and continue to
and now it's as lowest it's ever been
the economy is great the inflation is
dropping the stock market as high as
it's ever been Jan makes good point here
on YouTube because he brought up the
1031 which is exactly what I was talking
about earlier she brings up a good point
Maga won a cracker because this is what
they do they hear this [__] on Fox news
right they're sitting around
and I got a great clip to show you Joe
Biden talking about jerking on these
people jerking off the Fox News I'm not
kidding you this has got to be a
thousand percent real
but but she's right manga won a cracker
like the it's it's just a line for them
to repeat and listen to him repeat it
with this recording [__] where he uh
Hunter talked to a foreign someone who's
doing the deal with 1031 it's the FBI
document came out today and they were
talking about how there's a witness that
has recordings of talking to Hunter he
uh
received famine Hunter and some discount
and a business
I got the buzzwords right Hunter Joe
that's right five main bi document
five million dollars you know what it's
hilarious you know it's hilarious about
this [__] story more than anything
other than they're like uh there's
recordings that we've never heard
because they don't exist that that's
right that's great that's fantastic it's
a great [__] narrative
the fact is is that they're like the FBI
is weaponizing against Republicans in
the government but they collected
evidence against Hunter Biden Joe Biden
yeah and we're gonna get the forms and
we're gonna and the FBI is right about
this one like they're wrong about
everything else everything else about
Republicans they're wrong about but this
one instance we're an FBI agent did an
interview with someone it's completely
100 factual even though we have no
evidence to back it up
to the fact that that they love they
love to love the love to say that we're
gonna deep we're gonna defund the FBI
we're gonna defund the doj let's [__]
shut that [__] down oh okay what is your
alternative they do not have one and
then when Donald Trump makes a speech
you're telling me that if we defund the
FBI and doj there won't be any federal
law enforcement who will enforce the
laws if we do that is that what you're
saying well and then and then Donald
Trump in this most uh recent one of his
recent rallies host a post in
arraignment
um he talked about how he was going to
use the federal government which would
entail law enforcement I think you're
about to say the word weaponization here
soon
to get revenge
against Joe Biden by weaponizing yeah
the federal government such as the doj
and the FBI now if it's almost like it's
almost like they're doing this on
purpose that way if they need to
weaponize it their their cult will be
like well you weaponized against him so
weaponizing him March him to the gas
Chambers sounds familiar yeah sounds a
little sounds a little nutsy-ish I did
not see that guy yeah but that's that's
how they that's how they run right we
see it again and again and again and and
I and you know we were talking about
this yesterday but like kind of to
reiterate the point is during the
midterms
they
they ran on this idea you know actually
I was looking for today's thumbnail I
was looking for a photo of Jim trustee
right
and they came across this clip that was
10 months ago on Fox Business or Fox
News or something like that and he was
doing this interview about because it
was previously he worked in some
capacity for the Department of Justice I
guess right and he was trying he did
yeah trusting I forget what it was but
he was like a former prosecutor he he
previously worked in some capacity with
the doj I don't know if it was like a
Contracting position or whatever but you
know Fox News likes to embellish
people's titles and their resumes a lot
uh you know especially within the
Republican party however what happened
was I was looking for this I was looking
for a photo and I found this clip and I
watched this clip of Jim trustee and
what was he talking about he was talking
about 10 months ago
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden and these
payments and also uh his his uh the use
of the federal government to help Hunter
Biden and protect him so I was like oh
that's interesting so I might have to
pull that clip for later on on something
but
I wonder where he got that narrative at
who knows right I couldn't imagine who
would have given him that narrative or
why he would have gone around that or
with that right but
but you see them
they run on this platform right for 2022
midterms they said this is the thing
we're gonna fight we're gonna fight this
woke ass [__] we're gonna fight uh we we
just overturned Roe v Wade that's turned
that seems to be [__] biting Us in
the ass we're going to fight inflation
right uh though We're Not Gonna actually
propose anything and we're gonna vote
against all these bills and also we are
going to come after Joe Biden I mean Jim
Comer in September and October in
November December and then January
before they were they they barely won
the house and before they voted Uh Kevin
McCarthy NS speaker Jim Comer made tons
of promises on how he was going to
revamp the house and the oversight
committee to work them in to be this you
know non-weaponization of the federal
government to go against Joe Biden hold
him accountable right exactly wink wink
and what have we seen so far they have
run on this platform that it was gonna
be Joe Biden Hunter by we're gonna come
after them we're gonna we're gonna get
revenge and you know retribution and
we're gonna [__] own them and
weaponize the federal government
and now they have that position and
people are clamoring right Republicans
like arrest them arrest them arrest them
well you can't arrest anyone if there's
been no crimes okay and then now they're
like oh well we have these documents and
we have these informants and we have
these whistleblowers and we have these
tapes now Tony it is June 16 2023. now
the election doesn't happen until
next November 2024 no okay yeah we're a
little less than a year and a half away
from this okay
the idea that they I mean and they had
to right this is the hand they played
they they overplayed their hand and they
went in too early because they ran on
this idea that they were going to come
after Joe Biden and now that they
finally have the the control of the
house and the oversight committee they
only could do the the thing that they
had like the only play they could have
was
come forward with this evidence
and say they had tapes in this 1023 form
whatever the [__] it is
and what ends up happening is oh Chuck
Grassley and everyone else goes oh well
actually we don't know if these tapes
actually exist we haven't heard the
tapes we haven't seen the tapes we've
been told by this person that allegedly
these tapes exist
and now again it is June 16th and they
have overplayed their hand
they do not have any sort of narrative
that they can they can go forward with
because all their constituents are
saying arrest these Democrats arrest
these Democrats impeach Joe Biden but
there's nothing that they have on Joe
Biden or Hunter Biden or any of these
other Democrats to actually take uh you
know action against Law and Order right
and if they do defund the FBI and the
doj who's going to arrest those people I
have no idea I have no idea probably
Donald Trump himself speaking of that
let's go to boat end of the week we're
going to do a a great shift here boom
bone of the week
that was a great transition
um so because we got some great
boneheads this week so let's start the
music on stubborn in the week because
we're going to talk more about this in
both end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
a Ned of the week we got some great
bonuses
you got the bonehead of the century
Donald Trump
um there's a huge bonehead I always call
him uh Tommy to burville because he
thought there was two branches of
government when he was running for
Senator yeah
on a great two branches of our
government like what but that's probably
what they want you know they're like got
the two-tier justice system and there's
two to your government check your
balance yeah balances and and checks
does the checks balance in your chair
what did he think it was executive
branch and what was the other Branch uh
he couldn't think of them
you can only come up with two of them
there's probably there's a clip of it
somewhere because he did it in front of
a camera which is even better all right
or he did it on a radio show I don't
remember the rake stepping right amazing
oh speaking of rake stepping Tom Fenton
oh my god the guy he wears his little
sister's shirt holy [__] this guy the
non-legal advice coming from him to help
Donald Trump get indicted is beautiful I
really wanted to find a photo of Tom
fitton where he was smiling because I
wanted to see his father teeth does he
no he does he does smile right there's
actually there's actually a threat on
Twitter I saw earlier today where the
person's like this is Tom Finn he
doesn't know how to smile when there's a
camera
but uh I wanted it I wanted to show his
teeth but every time he showed his teeth
he was smiling and I'm like I'm not
trying to make you look
um good in a way but also her feet
they're making you look real [__]
right you look like a Method Man
um
Tom do you juice on meth is that what
you do probably yeah I mean I mean he's
definitely on gear yeah it probably is I
think he met this part of a stick and I
think I think he I think before he goes
into Mario spaces he takes a [__]
huge hit off the pipe oh really I think
he takes her oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean you can't see him he's on there
he's like
can you I I've never smoked meth so
that's that's obviously goes on is that
is that how you smoke meth yeah that's
how you smoke meth oh okay and you're
like oh that hits the hits the lungs
nice and deep black you know I I would
love to keep going on with Tom Finn but
I think we've done enough here just by
uh Gabe
um mimicking how he smokes meth before
he goes into Twitter spaces anyway I'm
just saying I'm just I'm just isn't it
great though isn't it great though that
we found out that the reason why Donald
Trump is indicted the reason why Donald
Trump continued the [__] lie about
the election uh which got him in hot
trouble with the special counsel now
probably the legal advice that Tom
Fenton was giving Trump in the in the
Manhattan D.A case
this non-lawyer Thompson he's such a
[__] idiot not only is he not a
lawyer he clearly does not know anything
about the law he just makes this [__] up
in his mind he started an organization
that has
I'm assuming lawyers on staff in some
capacity
and then he goes on as the talking head
of this quote unquote Legal Group and
says
oh you know this isn't actually a crime
or this impeachment of President Trump
was totally nonsense or uh this search
warrant it was an FBI raid and they went
in there unjustly and they didn't
actually have evidence to present
against him and why they had to go in
there and this and that and it turns out
that Tom fitton is the very reason that
that Donald Trump is in the [__] [__]
show that he's in right now that's right
well and you know I I encourage it and
that this morning the news again is that
Jim trustee
um the ambulance Chaser the TV lawyer uh
has walked away from the CNN defamation
case yeah I do want to I do want to
address a question here can you go back
to the three photos yeah yeah
all right so Amanda asks is Tom fitton
wearing blush and uh I had that this is
unedited I did not modify this photo at
all I just outlined his face I had the
very same question when I looked up I
was like wait is he wearing blush and
there was another one where I was like
wait does he wear blush maybe he does I
don't know but he could work again
Republicans they want to come after drag
and people from the lgbtq community but
then you find out that they maybe wear
makeup well or apparently interviews
apparently he's had gender uh affirming
surgery too on his chest
um oh we know we know yeah well we know
uh Crowder has yeah gender affirming
surgery on his chest because they felt
not manly enough that their chest was so
small right so they had you know sad
right but it's just funny how they their
bigots against other people having
gender affirming I mean that's that's
how the Republican party is right yeah
well it happens that way hey did you
know Jim trustee he's got a new
commercial out no yes well it's not new
he's just he's re-airing it I think the
reason why is because now he's not
Trump's lawyer anymore so he's got to
pick up some more clients let's listen
is your patriotic voice being canceled
did you try to overthrow the government
are you a former president who stole
highly classified documents well then
you need a lawyer you can trust hi I'm
Jim trustee and I'm a lawyer
really when I was charged with smearing
my own [__] on the walls of the Capitol
on January 6th Jim was there to defend
me and thanks to him finally got to
serve 16 months in prison I also teach
criminal courtroom evidence and trial
advocacy at the University of Maryland
when I took Jim trustee's course I
learned that stealing government
property was like as serious as like an
overdue library book oh and I almost
forgot now you can follow me on Twitter
for unsolicited legal takes so when you
need a lawyer you can trust remember to
call Jim trustee reached 184 easy
payments of 99.99 Jim trustee will maybe
help you too no money back guarantee uh
that is definitely not a real phone
number by the way yeah nobody should
ever call that phone number
not definitely not the real phone number
no for I supposed Jim trustee right
right I'm just I'm just saying
beard
that should we call her right now it
sure I don't give a [__] can you pull it
up yeah hang on
um it's kind of weird that the actual
attorneys
of trump are leaving him and the
non-attorneys are the ones staying
giving him well the now attorneys have
nothing left to at least the attorneys
are like [__] man if I stick around my
whole career is gone I may not be an
attorney anymore right
I mean you know attorneys like Christina
Bob or or uh
um Elena
what are you gonna say if they do answer
I'm gonna ask him for legal advice
that number may not be working anymore
because
because the commercial hasn't aired in a
while
yeah who knows
that's crazy
come on Jim hi this is Jim trustee
hi Jim trustee uh I'm just calling as a
prospective client wondering if you had
some open free time available would love
to get your thoughts on a current case
that I'm running
um yeah I guess I'll try you again maybe
on Monday when you're back in the office
um all right well I'll talk to you later
thanks goodbye
ah there you have it folks Jim trusty uh
it's a real [__] commercial I told
you it was real I told you it was real
I've been real I'm just saying dude I
don't [__] around with these commercials
dog oh son of a [__]
God damn it I'm all about the details
baby
the Easter egg and Gabe Sanchez's
material are are phenomenal they're
phenomenal what can I say this is what
you get some of the best Easter eggs in
the business speaking of Easter eggs
Tommy tuberville
couldn't find an Easter egg to save his
life right this guy's a [__] idiot
why is he on the bone end of the week I
think there's a certain reason yep yeah
yeah I gotta pull up the I mean you know
the main reason is that Tommy tuberville
is you know attacking attacking uh
veterans in terms of whoa whoa easy on
that Republicans love them Veterans as
political pawns okay
well they love Veterans as political
Pawns they like to use them once yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes and then they cast
them aside when they want you know like
healthcare and things like that right so
what it what is Tommy tuberville
actually doing in the Senate because
he's holding something up right yeah so
there's a and I just want to make sure I
get the the wording of this right hold
on okay so this is uh all right
this is the Tweet I'm just sending you
right now oh okay yeah I'll pull it up
here
but okay so uh the the Tweet here
says it's from uh Manu Raju uh from from
CNN so despite warnings from the
Pentagon Tommy cooperville doesn't buy
concerns over his hold on 250 military
promotions
and then as we'll see in this video but
he says I've talked to General and
Admirals and it felt like it was really
that it was
felt like it was really that much of a
problem we wouldn't be doing we wouldn't
be having this problem but it's likely
not affecting it uh and this is you know
a a I believe a domino effect right this
is not the first time that Tommy
tuberville is is going after the
military or veterans
but this is one example and there's more
to it as well uh but we'll play the
video first yeah so here's here's the
clip
from CNN
generals and Admirals and if I felt like
it was really that much of a problem we
wouldn't be having this problem but it's
really not affecting it they could do
these one at a time we could do three or
four a day if they're really that
concerned about it but nobody's
concerned about it and so why would I be
concerned about it if I if I didn't I
don't get conversation from the leader
uh
and uh you know Pentagon I mean what are
you supposed to do
but Lloyd Austin defense secretary has
in fact raised concerns about these
holds and warning that this could hurt
National Security hurt military
preparedness but if you could hear
tuberville there he simply does not
believe that he said that they wanted to
move through these one by one they can
do it even though it would eat up
enormous amount of floor time something
Democrats don't want to do to give into
this Jake he does want a vote on the
full senate floor to essentially codify
that Pentagon abortion policy Democrats
don't want to give him to that so the
standoff is going to persist so this has
to do with abortion huh or at least
that's what Tommy tuberville is making
this out to be yeah because in the
remaining parts of the Tweet he says two
real says that he wants to vote on the
senate floor of the pentagon's abortion
policy and it fails he wants him to drop
the policy he won't accept an amendment
in committee and then just now in the
floods of June 15th the kind of behavior
just steals my resolve Tommy drewville
sells on the floor just now on attacks
of over his hold won't accept a vote on
committee a show vote in committee is
not good enough demands floor vote and
objects to Democrat effort to confirm
nominees right and then and the reason
the reason we bring this up and it was
brought to our attention is because of
uh you know Miss love speak and I sent
you another tweet in here which is
Senator Mike Lee and Tommy tuberville
are blocking promotions for the military
because they want to control female
members and female veteran veterans
bodies blocking this endangers National
Security so basically from her words I
sacrificed my life and I'm disabled and
it doesn't matter and that's that is the
the sick and sad truth of
of the Republican party right they're
willing to hold people's livelihood to
hold People's Health Care to hold
people's existence of life
just dangling there as a prop
and Tommy tuberville doesn't really care
about those things Republicans don't
really care about things like you said
earlier right they they use them as a
political prop they use them as
something to toy around with like it's a
cat playing with like a a fly on the
ground right it's not quite dead yet but
they're playing with it for the sake of
playing with because they can't they
have the power and the influence to to
to you know uh exert that that could
that kind of uh Power or the that
control over them and
it's it's sick because not only is it
holding up these confirmations because
what we learned in 2001 right in 2000
2001 when the transition of power
happened from uh from but whether it was
going to be Gore or bush right and
leading into Bush right there was a
period of time in which we were not
prepared we're not ready from a military
standpoint in terms of preparedness
right and some people believe there that
Gap in time in which we fought it on
whether it was going to be Bush or Gore
led us to a position of vulnerability
that led to September 11th right
and the same things are discussed around
this this halt or prevention of a
transition of power from uh from Trump
to Biden from the 2000 or 2020 to 2021
election period right and we see that
when we don't have enough time to
prepare ourselves then it does bite Us
in the ass right we do we are vulnerable
we we don't have us the preparedness or
the security measures in place and I
believe this is in you know Miss love
speak in the chat can correct when I'm
what I'm speaking on but the idea that
preventing these or halting these
confirmations will harm our country in
our national security right especially
something that Republicans want to fight
so and pound their chest we have to be
secure on our national border
internationally we have to be secure
this and that but if they if they hold
up this these promotions they're it's
going to it's going to be a negative
effect on our own security right and
actually in the chat right here miss
love speak says two reveals black
devotions for the military because they
want to control female numbers and
female veterans bodies blocking this in
danger is now security and women in the
military
and and Republicans are just okay with
it right well these are these are the
same people who not only not only uh
encourage the overturning of Roe v Wade
but
wanted to go much steps further I mean
these are the same people that that
created a law in Texas where there's
bounties on on women's bodies and and
their bodily autonomy it's not
surprising right that this group of
people or the same group of people
trying to block these these these
promotions that are have to be done by
the Senate
um and also and also it's just it really
comes back this idea that Republicans
don't actually care about those things
like freedom and security and
Independence and all this and that right
it really goes to expose them that they
could not give two shits and it also
goes to show that they have not learned
their lesson
from overturning Roe v Wade and say well
we got to send it back to the States and
then the states and the and the citizens
decided no no no no that's we're not
going to allow that state constitution
uh abortion ban passing through and then
Republicans got super pissed off because
it wasn't what they thought was going to
happen right they expected a different
outcome someone in YouTube channel asked
what they can do what you can do is you
can call your Senator and you can call
the Senators that are blocking this uh
Lee and tuberville uh one last thing for
Miss love speak and then I want to I
want to move to uh I want to move to
Izzy the a yeah the alpha guck I want to
move to the office yeah
um Miss love speak says holding up the
promotions for open command seats is
currently endangering uh us right now
and that that's really at the heart of
this is that they claim their you know
they want National Security and strong
National Security and blah blah blah
blah blah blah oh this is the same
[__] that yell and scream Law
and Order and when Donald Trump receives
Law and Order like oh this is a Witch
Hunt so it's the same [__] they don't
care they never had cared about the
military they don't care about veterans
they don't care about their health care
they don't care about their service they
don't give a [__] they haven't gave a
[__] again they just use it as a
political talking point that's it that's
all it is it's just political talking
point that's why Tommy tuberville is
using the abortion thing to hold up
these [__] nominations because they
want to go into next year indeed
election saying Biden has endangered our
national security because he hasn't
promoted Military Officers I guarantee
you they're going to say that [__]
they're not going to tell the story of
why why they couldn't get these military
promotions because a bunch of [__]
bigoted ass Republicans are using
abortion as a wedge issue to knock these
promotions through and that's why the
Democrats are like no we're not going to
play your stupid games doing these one
by one we know what you're gonna do
because Republicans are going to use
that next year if they do that if they
do that on the senate floor they're
going to say oh they wasted all this
time to do these one by one Republicans
are literally going to say that [__] and
but the reason why they are going to do
them one by one if they if that is the
case it's because of Republicans right
it's all political talking points it's
all political and the fact that they
want to control women's bodies right
they couldn't do it they they couldn't
successfully do it with this overturning
of Roe v Wade and hoping that's the the
states would actually uh put it pass it
through yeah and there you go he's doing
but that's what I'm saying is they're
using abortion and they're using their
bases
um just feverish feverish hatred towards
women and women's bodily autonomy to
wedge this issue they you can't you
can't Tommy tuberville and Mike Lee
can't stand there and go well we're not
going to promote people in the military
unless they couple it with because we
hate women right I mean if they just
stood there and like nope don't want to
do this because I don't want to do this
well that wouldn't fly they have to have
the excuse that their base needs their
excuse that their base needs is that
they hate women that's good enough for
the base just like the next Story the
album
Giuliani this [__] wild ass story
about these stupid recordings right and
again I showed you the video of the guy
standing in the thing yelling and
screaming about Trump and he said to 10
31 and the FBI and and he had all like
he said he had all the buzzwords in
there and he's like Joe Biden five
million dollars Hunter Biden and Biden's
more of a criminal than Crump Trump
Crump that could be yeah yeah sure crime
Crump yeah it's kind of coming he's the
bigger criminal than Trump and that's
the narrative folks The Narrative isn't
that hey Trump's a criminal we should
abandon him it's well we're not going to
abandon Trump because he's a criminal
because you're not abandoning Biden
right it's all it's all in an effort to
solidify the base to Rally around the
criminal Trump and here is Rudy um
because he's the alpha cook there's some
new news this morning apparently he used
an alias of Helen in emails oh yeah yeah
in this fake elector scheme I didn't
read through this yet but what what is
that about this have you read through
that yet I haven't read through it yet
but I'm I'm uh that might be part of
your what was that you might need that
you might need that this is uh wouldn't
be surprised that he lied and but he he
used a woman's name think about that so
not only did Rudy Giuliani years ago
dress up in Drag and Donald Trump yeah
yeah motorboated in his fake boobs when
he was in drag but now he's using Helen
so he's dragging on each side I mean he
didn't drag on email yeah that's weird
what are you saying well I mean we'll
we'll yeah I mean like based on what
this says right now it says Rudy
Giuliana used an email address with the
name Helen and some of his
Communications but his efforts to oppose
president former president Trump's 2020
election loss Julian the former New York
[__] idiot uh discussed his own uh
he's got his use of the email address R
helen0528 gmail.com in a court
appearance as part of defamation lawsuit
filed against him by Rudy Ruby Freeman
and uh Andrea Shea Moss if you remember
those are the two Georgia election
workers they spoke uh they gave
testimony during the Jan six hearings
and we learned that there was no thumb
drive it was a ginger mint and because
of Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump they
ruined these two women's lives where
they felt like they could use their name
out in public they couldn't be in a
grocery store and call out to her mother
or daughter because they were afraid
that somebody would know that name right
and they would harass them or Worse
right right commit violence acts no but
they moved didn't she had a move I
believe they I think Ruby Freeman had to
like move because they were they were
[__] docks in them and and right now
what's even weirder is he says in this
uh this article he goes that was my main
Gmail account since I had Gmail
what is Rudy's middle name did did he
put pronouns on this email like in the
signature like Helen Giuliani she her
I want to know who the Helen is here
like if I look at his middle name he's
got two he's got William Lewis so
nowhere close to Helen because I mean
that could be a thing where Rudy's
middle name is Helen sometimes you know
that happens let's see does this did his
second cousin that he married have the
name Helen
if for anyone he doesn't know Rudy
Giuliani the guy who had [__] leaking
from his temples and from his ear he
married his second cousin yeah that's
real that's real Yeah
well yeah it says here that his first
Gmail account was this R helen0528 which
again I haven't found anyone connected
to him
oh wait oh oh here we go oh you know
what is it his mom's name someone's
saying it's his mom's name Giuliani was
born in 1944 in East Flatbush section
blah blah blah the only child of working
class parents Helen
and Harold Angelo Jones using his mom's
name on email well part of it right
because it's R Helen well that
so is it Rudy Helen R Helen
that's [__] weird though man it is
very weird you remember the story about
the guy in Pennsylvania who committed
election fraud yeah yeah he killed his
wife and then and then he used his dead
mother and yeah yeah there we go yeah he
uses dead mother-in-law's uh name to
vote do you think that's what Rudy's
doing is he using his mom's name this is
this is you think he's like hi I'm Helen
I'm Rudy's mom is his mom still alive or
is she dead his his mama's dead she died
in the article it says Juliana's mother
thank goodness she didn't see the
downward spiral of her son she's already
gone is it somehow others were created
for specific purposes but that would
cover 95 of any email I had and probably
every important one the guy that's
[__] weird anyway Juliana's mother
who passed away in 2002 was named Helen
in an email to TM TPM Juliana's order
Joe Sibley pointed to this fact when
asked why Giuliani was not using an
email address with his own name but
again
I don't know how that how that excuses
the fact that
was he signing these emails with his
name or Helen
that's a good question however
but there's another one he had another
one so our helen058 was not the only
mysterious address cc'd on Waldron's
message Waldron also copied Lucy three
four one three again you know it's when
someone's like hey I'm random username
three four six seven eight nine ten you
know like it's something like that you
know where it sounds like oh I'm totally
gonna take this account seriously
uh but it says here an encrypted email
service the committee filing did not
include any response from Giuliani to
Walter's message Waldron and Meadows
Mark Meadows did not respond to requests
for comment on the story Lucy three four
one three also did not respond of course
because it's [__] Rudy Giuliani or it
might be Mark Metals who knows right uh
this is nuts this is nuts and the reason
why it's nuts is this is like George
Santos type [__] right yeah this is
literally this is George Santos type
stuff where he's using his mom's name in
an email it's [__] weird man uh so
there's also oh my God there's also
other ones too oh Jesus there's another
one
so there's also requested request three
personal accounts the r Helen zero five
two eight and another Alias on an
encrypted service called Truth Injustice
for you oh God yes small rant had that
here look here
there it is truth and justice for you
yeah yeah that was at the end see the
audience see you guys are on top yeah
why do we even come here every day I
don't even know dude you guys could run
this show by yourself just do it you
know that's what we'll do all right I'll
sleep in
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding we're
back we're back
um David David does a huge throwback
here look at this one
I would use Carlos Danger do you
remember who Carlos Danger is that is
that's a wild throwback that's Anthony
Weiner Anthony Weiner would use the
Alias Carlos Danger and and uh it's
funny because it happened when Jon
Stewart uh was doing his movie when he
was still The Daily Show and and um John
Oliver filled in for him yeah is when
the huge the Anthony Weiner story blew
up and it's funny that that happened
because Jon Stewart and Anthony Weiner
were actually roommates at one point did
you know that no yes they were roommates
at one point and so they know each other
personally but then John had to come out
and start you know telling the truth and
smashing Anthony but when John Oliver
was on the air they'd play danger
for for Carlos Danger this is wild
throwback
um and really honestly hey there was
more George Santos before George Santos
right yeah yeah and Carlos Danger or
Anthony Weiner was one of them yeah well
is Anthony Weiner had like when it came
to
his name use in public he went by
actually a real name right even though
it is a wild name wiener right yeah yeah
I mean totally could have changed it
because weiner is you know I mean
considering what he did it was like oh
man right was this I mean he was
literally he was literally taking
pictures of his weiner yeah and sending
it to people like when you hear his name
first you're like oh that's that's a
funny thing yeah what's his real name no
it's actually Anthony Weiner right and
you're like oh what what's his nickname
then Carlos Danger yeah oh well that oh
that sounds like it should be backwards
really yeah like he should be Carlos
Danger and he went by and I mean you
could say oh wiener danger you know we
oh that's true
oh so thanks for that throwback here's a
clip of Rudy over the weekend
um talking about this wild story about
these recordings that don't exist and we
know they don't exist because it's Rudy
talking about them
um just like Helen doesn't exist that
the email Helen doesn't exist the the
Trump And Justice For You doesn't exist
it's Al Rudy we know that it's all fake
right but here he is saying oh yeah that
person that has all those fake
recordings that Republicans don't have
to keep talking about about the the fake
ass bribery scheme that the binder part
of that guy's dead the witness crazy
let's listen on a day in which uh we
find out that the bidens took a 10
million dollar bribe
from a Ukrainian mycolo wait wait I
thought it was five
that was five it was five I thought it
was I thought it was five it was five
and then and then it updated did it
change
or is this a different there's this
different recordings different bribery
scheme because they were like uh five
million that's that's not how much money
Donald Trump owes each and Carol and
they're like we gotta double this oh
okay I see they gotta you gotta do it
they gotta play it that way they watch
way too much TV don't you think they
watch way too much [__] it's like one
million dollars and then they laugh at
them yeah like they're like 10 million
dollars like like dude just because you
keep upping it doesn't make it any
better like literally that's what
they're doing okay let's listen to
[__] hell in here let's listen to
Helen tell us the rest of the story you
know and did tell them three years ago
and uh they followed up on none of the
evidence I gave them uh they were hoping
the people because they were dying right
uh it's extraordinary I I gave them one
witness that any investigator would uh
jump through hoops to go to gave him the
witness who is a woman who was the chief
accountant at the security company
Barista yeah she was the wife of the
former owner who died under suspicious
circumstances oh Jesus uh and uh she was
willing to give up all of the offshore
bank accounts including the bidens
what happened Tony tell me what happened
she was gonna do it she was willing to
do it what happened she died oh
yeah and there's no tapes now apparently
they don't exist you know what's crazy
is I know a guy who knows a guy who
knows this other guy who goes by Helen
who might use the email every once in a
while Trump and justice for for you or
for all or whatever it is yeah yeah and
and
that's it and he he goes and he dressed
up in drag he lets down Trump get in his
bosoms his drag bosoms uh in the 90s and
then he knows a guy who knows another
guy who knows this guy who led parnass
knows who went overseas to see this
other guy who knows the guy who knows a
gal who this gal is a cousin of this guy
who owns this company yeah follow me
here this is [__] wild and not only
is it one million five million 10
million we're talking 200 million
dollars and there's a laptop it's
probably 100 binds it's probably got
cocaine in it it's probably got blow
it's probably got meth and there's
definitely pictures of Hunter Biden
[__] prostitutes in it which makes
Biden totally more of a criminal than
Trump you follow all that got it
um
no okay well that's the story I guess
okay well I guess that's the that's the
whole caboodle and that a g isn't that
genius you know what you know what's
funny is our dishonorable mention told
the story on the vote can you pull that
clip of Jack Grassley telling this story
yeah it almost when he's telling the
story on the floor of the Senate that's
almost what it sounds like what I was
just that gibberish I was just talking
about it almost sounds exactly the same
and that's why Rudy Giuliani is the
alpha cook but Chuck Grassley is
dishonorable mention this week is
because this kind of story is one and
the same but again I'm telling you folks
it's not about the story it's not about
the amount you've seen him go from 5
million to 10 million to go to 100
million they'll say there's six
recordings in their 17 then there's 15
100 but only two a Joe and then they
call barismo well what really
bereavement was someone who knew about
debris they're gonna change the story
time and time again to keep it in the
news and the reason why is because they
need their base to believe that Joe
Biden is more of a criminal than Donald
Trump to keep backing Donald Trump
that's it that's all they need that's
all the stories for this is not to hurt
Joe Biden in the election that's not
what this is about if it was they would
they would be dropping this story next
year in October yeah not now they're
doing it now
to make sure that the Maga base keeps
backing their criminal candidate because
the other guy's a criminal too so why
not back our criminal but again like I
said earlier they have they played their
hand to wait they showed their hand way
too early and they overplayed it because
now they have nothing left to push on
this Biden tape hunter
conspiracy that they had taken 10
million dollars in some bribery case
uh no it turns out that it's all a lie
and there's nothing there and you hear
it in this in this uh we have a video
though it's from our boy Benji Johnson
oh yeah Benji that [__] idiot but
here is here is here is uh and listen
when he says because they're not gonna
say they're not gonna say that it's real
they're gonna say allegedly right
allegedly they're gonna be very careful
how they say it find the other one of
him well well actually the one I want is
not uh Grassley the one-on-one is of Ron
Johnson because that Russian asset has
been pushing this too there's a recent
one interview of him talking about
yesterday yes if you'll pull that while
while I'm playing this let me assist for
the purposes of more transparency on
this subject
the 1023 produced
to the house committees no no Chuck
Grassley the guy said 10 31. yeah that's
what he said now add it right which one
is it 10 31 10 23 what are you guys
doing here guys this is [__] amateur
out the Apollo 1023 is an actual FBI
form do you know what a 1031 is
I don't know man I know what a 10 40 is
a 1031 is a tax exchange where you you
exchange likes ass [__] where you
exchange like assets for like assets and
then you you use you use an Arbiter wait
wait wait that makes sense then oh
really because there's some kind of Mega
is there some kind of meganomics here no
no no no just think about it okay you
said assets right ass assets you said
assets right so what kind of assets are
we talking maybe it could be Russian
assets it could be we're using one
Russian asset for another Russian asset
yeah that that's where they don't tax
Russian assets I don't know man I'm just
saying I'm just saying it sounds like
don't don't push me down because there
might be something here I'm just saying
scratch enough you might smell something
well let's let's smell what Chuck
Grassley is stepping in I'm thinking
it's all [__] redacted reference
that the foreign National who allegedly
bribed Joe and Hunter Biden allegedly
allegedly allegedly audio recording
allegedly of his conversation allegedly
17.
such recording allegedly yeah according
to the 1023
the foreign National possesses 15 audio
recordings of phone calls between him
and Hunter bike
according to the 10 23
the foreign National possesses two audio
recordings of phone calls between him
and then Vice President Joe Biden
these recordings were allegedly kept the
sort of insurance policy for the foreign
National in case that he got into a
tight spot
okay so there's the the three we heard
we heard at least three allegedly's in
there now I don't know if there's more
legislies in a like longer version but
again Chuck Grassley has to be very
careful that he's not
he's not claiming
that they actually did this thing but he
has to say well there you know because
what he's doing right now it's all
hearsay well the other reason why they
have to say allegedly is because they
draw Hunter Biden into it Hunter Biden
is not the President Hunter Biden's not
running for president Hunter binding is
not a public he's not publicly elected
or public official because you can sling
all kinds of mud at a publicly elected
official and you don't have to use the
word allegedly but when you're doing it
to a private citizen they can [__]
sue you for defamation is what they can
do so that's why they have to continue
to do this because they draw they've
drawn Hunter by ninja and I'll be sues
the [__] out of all of them right yeah I
hope he just shoots the [__] out of all
of them of course because they knew they
know here's the thing they know what
they're they're doing and in this and in
this speech or this like little floor
speech that he gave uh
nowhere in there does he clarify that
he's never seen
or heard these tapes right he says
allegedly
but he doesn't explicitly say oh well I
haven't seen these tapes I haven't uh I
haven't uh seen him with my eyes I
haven't seen a photo of them I haven't
seen a video of these tapes I haven't
heard these tapes there's no evidence
that they exist other than this person
had said they do right and this person
is probably our helen0528 who knows you
know right it is her and she is dead
um someone says Hunter Biden is only one
thing cool I'm telling you hookers and
blow I I you know I'm not gonna
disparage because sex workers work and
really honestly if you're if you're
gonna you know have a bunch of
prostitutes want to have a bunch of blow
too I'm just saying it seems like they
go together uh maybe Ron Johnson I mean
according to Madison cawthorne the
Republican Party The GOP they have sex
orgies right so I think they should be
the last group to throw stones right or
cocaine rocks uh let's listen to Ron
Johnson here let's see if he can give us
proof of why these tapes
our [__] [__] let's see first of
all let's clarify this yeah what the FBI
had was a report from a confidential
human Source who had obtained
information from a top executive of the
uh Oil Company Ukrainian oil company
barisma uh that individual that
executive apparently told this Source
about this scheme uh this bribery scheme
to pay the bidens in total 10 million
dollars and that that's
executive told the source that he had
made uh phone conversations do you see
what I mean by hey I know a guy who
knows a guy who knows this guy so this
guy told this other guy there's this guy
named Larry he has a yellow raincoat
he's at the end of the drive-through for
the the Burger King on 40th and 7th now
if you go to him and you say the magic
word of
badun just like that Baden and say
Hunter's dick he'll give you all the
info you need really yeah that's pretty
good yeah that's pretty good well let's
finish it's a special keyword let's
let's finish up the uh uh 28 000 Degrees
of Kevin Bacon here recorded 15 times
with Hunter Biden twice with Joe Biden
I'm not aware that we have verified that
those recordings exist
so why are you talking about it then you
just he was like so this person told
this person and this person said this
thing and they said they told it's like
[__] Ferris Bueller's my cousin's
sister's boyfriends twice removed
uncle's nephew salt [__] Hunter Biden
at Baskin Robbins getting three scoops
and passed out because he was high from
Coke it's weird [__] man it's weird
stuff but you know again the whole aim
of it again I want you I want to explain
to the audience why narrative is so
important
why why misinformation is so important
to them and the reason why is because
the video I showed you the guy who was
puking this [__] up in front of someone
as if the reason why he's still
supporting Trump is because Joe Biden is
more of a criminal and that's the whole
aim of it it has nothing to do and you
also you also like how he gets through
all of this stuff he's like oh this
person this person this person they did
this thing they said this thing they did
this thing they said this thing and at
the end he goes now we haven't verified
so he just spends like 30 seconds and
probably before that as well talking
about it but like 30 seconds or so
discussing how this thing
is real right this thing has been told
to them that it's real it exists it's
it's valid it's and then at the very end
and he goes but we also cannot confirm
if these things are real yeah they're
probably not it's probably all [__]
is what he's saying he's playing it's
all [__] but act like it's real act
like it's real because it's complete
under [__] of course it is of course
it is that's what made Chuck Grassley
the song will mention and really
honestly all this [__] came from Helen
Giuliani in the first place
do we call God damn giuliani's mom do we
do we call him Helen from now on I don't
know I don't know I mean might as well
yeah it's true uh it's the same thing as
when uh our bonehead of the week winner
used to use the name John Barron yeah to
promote himself I Know Rich Donald Trump
is a rich rich man right uh or who are
you I'm John Barron I'm definitely not
Donald Trump yeah I'm like him and the
number the phone number
Donald Trump I'm John Barron how big are
John Barron's hands dude you know how
big they are they're like this big
John Barron I'm the best
Joe Biden
enemy of the stage oh my god oh that's
right the guy speaks nonsense man that's
right Donald Trump is the winner here on
bonehead of the week of course he is how
could he not be like okay so I know
there's a lot of [__] going around but
why I'm I'm trying to think of the
reason why he's on bonehead of the week
uh is it why do we put Donald Trump okay
so oh oh it was because
was there something that happened was
there something about those people he
said he was going to pay for the [__]
Meal please [__] the indictments [__]
the arraignment like we know he's a
criminal right after can you give me the
clip of this this is green so Donald
Trump right after he gets [__]
indicted and it rained on 37 uh Federal
felonies for breaking the Espeon
Espionage Act because he's stealing and
harboring our documents and then he's
obstructing justice this [__]
goes to a restaurant and he goes in and
he he looks to see if the cameras are
there and they're rolling right and he
says I'm gonna buy everyone's food right
true Donald Trump Rich billionaire style
if you are a real billionaire if you're
not a real billionaire you just say it
out loud and then you [__] cut and
run with the on the check what do they
call it dine and dash
so basically he went and did a dining
dash for the whole restaurant you got
everyone riled up he was like look guys
I'm gonna pay for your meal it's all
covered everyone's like whoa this guy
loves us I [__] love this man and
then he [__] dipped down he's like
all right there's nothing distracted
[__] people man I'm trying to find
this clip right now it's uh because
anytime I look for it that that that is
I you know I don't know why you guys
voted for Donald Trump for about another
week but that is that is the most
bone-headed thing and it's not really
him being bone netted it's how his
support and again that's why the story
about the [__] Biden things right
like well Donald Trump's really he's a
scumbag right he's a criminal he's a
crook he's he's he's [__] he's
probably compromised yeah sure whatever
but Joe Biden's much worse because of
five million dollars I mean actually 10
million let's make it 10 million that
sounds way worse and let's say 10 31
just to you know get that going so
here's the clip of Donald Trump
promising he's going to um he's going to
pay for their meals
um yeah this is now caught in 4k what
oh [__] okay and here's the thing like I
guarantee this restaurant like you know
it's a it's a was this is it called
Versailles is that what it's called yeah
yeah yeah okay
Cuban restaurant yeah here's the thing
here's the thing
there's a town in Missouri right and
it's spelled this way right like versus
like Versailles like like in France
right correct yeah
been there very nice place and in
Missouri the town not that place I've
been known we don't we don't call it
Versailles we call it Versailles oh god
oh the Double L man I'm just telling you
for sales it's called Versailles so
whenever I mean if it was one L it would
be Versailles
I get it I get it this is Missouri okay
or misery listen we call it Versailles
so every time I see this story and
someone type it out like Versailles
that's great Versailles is a Cuban
restaurant that's [__] hilarious okay
here's here's Donald Trump he's gonna
promise everyone he always gonna buy
their food he's gonna buy their food
this is after this is after the woman
that's in the red there yeah she's like
a preacher or whatever right did she
pray over him she prayed over him in
another in another video she prayed over
in me and then and then he did this oh
this is great so so he did like the
Jesus thing where he turns [__] water
into wine here by buying everybody
[__] food but he doesn't do it he
doesn't actually yeah okay let's see are
you ready are you ready food for
everyone food
for everyone he says are you ready are
you ready like are you recording yeah is
everyone ready for this big ass surprise
right yeah and I want you to yell on the
screen let's watch it again geez Jesus
are you ready are you ready food for
everyone
he didn't say he was gonna buy it I mean
at a restaurant at a restaurant
for everyone at a restaurant like that's
the whole [__] point right right yeah
you're like okay are you ready are you
are you ready are you guys looking I got
a great idea I got a great idea I got a
great idea it's for a restaurant and
what you do in this place in this
building food for everyone in this house
he solved hunger in that restaurant for
everyone that's like when he was like
you know those people with those antifa
with those cans those Soup cans soup
from my family soup for my family
I mean technically it is oh I mean he
ain't wrong you know the crazy part is
is he said that that way that way when
when that when we're starting to accuse
him that he was promising to buy people
food and then he didn't he said I never
promised to buy [__] people I never
promised I just promised there's food
for everybody's a restaurant what do you
want me to do there's three for
everybody he goes I said a true
statement and I let them believe Eve I
was gonna pay for it like everything
else I do I let them believe that I'm
going to protect them I'm going to
Pardon them I'm going to make sure that
I use all of my money that you gave me
to help you out right
because I'm the only one standing in
their way when they're coming after you
which they're actually coming after me
because I'm indicted right I'm the one
indicted not you which the other thing
is I don't know if you let me see if I
can find the video but uh I I didn't
read through what the the instructions
by the judge were okay
but I saw something that said like
because Walt NADA is a witness
he can't well he's not he's not he's not
a witness he's a co-defendant there's a
difference okay okay he's a co-defendant
and a co-conspirator
it's a there's a difference and he
cannot they they cannot coordinate
um like even like their legal team like
Donald Trump can they be seen in the
same place together uh well they they
most certainly can be seen in the same
place together but they can't coordinate
their efforts on this case got it okay
and and they're I mean in most in in
most federal cases like this there's
conditions of someone being released
right um a lot of times it's travel
restriction on where you can go a lot of
times you got to give a passport if you
have firearms you gotta hand over your
Firearms to to the feds or you gotta you
got they have to verify that you gave
them to like a family member or
something they're not stored at your
residence where you have access to them
which is kind of [__] stupid that
these two a Bros yell and scream about
the Second Amendment it's uninfringible
but they infringe it every [__] day
when you're indicted or if you're a
felon they do it all the time and this
idea that's inalienable is [__] dumb
but
because they never [__] about that but
the craziest part about
um his release is that he's not going to
be able to talk to Witnesses about this
case which everyone around him is a
[__] witness to this yeah like
everyone at Mar-A-Lago is a [__]
witness to this anyone who was anywhere
near him when he was doing this or he's
talking about these documents things and
you know he talks about it all the time
he's he's just a [__] animal he's
just like oh my God you're my documents
I stole them I stole them in their mind
and yeah I put them in the bathroom I
mean [__] I sit there and take a dump it
I sit there and take a [__] and I read
them the classified documents here look
here see them Tony read them he looks at
the maps look look here look this is a
classified document look here see this
see this classified document see I can't
show it to you don't look don't get too
close you can't see this you're not
you're not you don't have to you don't
have the certification but this is nice
I stole this from the government fair
and square it's mine okay it's really
weird [__] so everyone's a witness
really technically around him right yeah
I mean anyone who has ever seen Donald
Trump at Mar-A-Lago is
a witness
so Donald Trump again wins bonehead of
the week
um and I wish we could say it's because
he was indicted in a rain but you know
what we expect that we expect more to
come so why not make him the moment of
the week for promising to buy everyone
food and solve hunger in the restaurant
right that's what he did he solved
hunger in the restaurant food for
everyone are you ready are you ready are
ready to get this on tape are you ready
to get this on tape food food for
everyone
hey
it's almost like there's a menu that you
can pick out what you want you got this
you got this like everyone in the back
he's like you got this you got this okay
food for everyone food for everyone
oh my God I just farted
this is [__] wild [__] but this is
where we are for bone of the week let's
give Grandpa poopy pants and Cheeto dust
cueing on her the restaurant hunger
solver is due
[Music]
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]
God there wasn't even a chance for them
again
or something like that Grandpa felony
out front the whole way man you never
stopped he never stopped solving hungry
[Music]
yeah
well that's bonehead of the week stick
around we're gonna have some
announcements we'll talk for a few more
minutes right after the sound
foreign
[Applause]
it's basically the whole show really
because we I mean they're just [__]
boneheads man that's what the show is
like maybe we should just switch it from
the Tony Michaels podcast to just a
bunch of boneheads yeah like just
boneheads boneheads I like the the
um uh the you know bunch of boneheads BB
what do they call that
when you start you start each word
that's not alliteration though because
you have oh it's a bunch of boneheads
[__] you all right but if you called it
if you called it bonehead bunch then
that's alliteration bonehead Bunch
that's what we should do now this
morning we were doing the thumbnail and
we were trying to come up with what
we're gonna do with the the trusty story
and the Trump story and that's where I
went the um what was it loser loser
losing lawyer yeah loser losing lawyer
yeah lll yeah Triple L just take the L
dude boom just take the L and I thought
that was a good one I thought this guy
you win with it you went with it you
liked that I mean I'm I'm all for
alliteration you know right you know
especially like I love a good
alliteration like on a on a Crayola
crayon you know oh really yeah when
they're like it's like plumptious purple
or something like that you know like
alliteration like that yeah what it kind
of helps to roll off the tongue right
it's easy
not that one sorry hold on the chat's
coming they come in so quick you know
BYOB bring your um that's good that's
good BYOB bring your own bone in I mean
they have a lot of them to bring there
you could do a whole basket of them a
basket of boneheads again
a bonehead basket a BB it's
um basket of boneheads big bonehead bash
ooh because you're bashing the boneheads
yeah yeah okay I see it I see yeah I can
see it I can see it too oh man
what are you doing this weekend you
having fun this weekend you gonna have
fun this weekend
I actually I've got a friend visiting on
Sunday oh yeah so he's gonna come into
town and we're gonna go just hang out
he's gonna drink some Bud Light last
night yeah dude I'm missing some queer
ass beer last night so
um
someone may have reminded me that I
needed to we needed to do bone in the
week because yeah [__] forget every
week great the moderators
um they're they're always saving our ass
on that but here's the thing is last
night I was um
I may or may not have been drinking uh
queer beer uh at a at a live music event
double fisting that [__] [__] man so
woke so woke
you know it unfortunately it didn't make
me feel gay at all
well yeah I was really black out did you
wake up no no no no I was pretty drunk I
was pretty drunk I was dancing a lot I
danced almost the whole time like my
[__] life is gay yeah well and I you
know I made the mistake because this was
outside it's hotter it's hotter than a
[__] yeah right now here and
it's human as [__] so I made a mistake I
wore a gray shirt and uh by the end of
the night I was I [__] look like it
was dark we did it go from light gray to
dark gray well no but did you see the uh
did you see how Ron DeSantis was
sweating at the one event yeah yeah and
I I kind of look like that oh man well I
mean you have an excuse though you were
dancing you were drinking that's true
Rhonda Sanchez was just trying to spit
out some words at a podium
a robot but I I did I did um I
I did make that mistake and I won't make
that mistake again yeah but I did have
fun it was a lot of what you wear black
man well right and I usually wear a
black shirt like today I got on um dark
gray but yeah dark gray I should have
wore the black National shirt from last
night that's the yeah well this is I'm
still sweating yes yeah yeah it's still
profusely yeah right it's crazy this is
me still sweating from last night I
haven't even taken a shower it's I'm
still I'm still I get it no it's June in
the midwest you know things it's hotter
than a [__] you ever been to
Missouri in the summer it's hotter than
[__] I haven't oh my God
I know exactly what that's like yeah
that's horrible isn't it yeah okay no I
don't need to go back someone asked
someone asked a question did Tony talk
about Garth Brooks this week uh a little
bit but um I I posted on on Twitter
um about Garth Brooks and you're I think
you're referring to the um the the beer
the Bud Light Scandal of Garth Brooks
and at CMA Fest and I think we talked
about this didn't we talk about this we
did because I mentioned it yeah GMA Fest
was over the weekend last weekend yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and the reason
why it was so significant at the time
and why Garth Brooks has taken such heat
is because there was thousands of people
in Nashville for CMA Fest and when they
went into his bar he was serving Bud
Light so that that's that's what he was
that's what he was you know and that's
why he took the heat but he went on his
Facebook uh page and they lost their
minds like Benny Benji Johnson that
[__] little [__] he's like Garth
Brooks is feeling the Heat
he's got he's gonna get canceled I'm
like what what the [__] are you do do
you have any idea who Garth Brooks is
Garth Brooks is the biggest country
music star of all time the dude doesn't
have to sing another [__] verse he
never has to strum a guitar again and
he'll never run out of money what the
[__] are you talking about you think
people from the 1980s and 1990s who
listen to country music and love country
music are gonna boycott Garth Brooks
you're a [__] dumb as dog [__] this
is the dumbest thing I've ever heard and
DC Drano uh Rogaine you remember this
game oh yeah yeah yeah talking about he
was talking about the other day he was
like oh we're gonna destroy the the
coward 20 these Rhino Republic we're
gonna destroy them and we're gonna get
rid of them like we did Bud Light and
Target I'm like look man hey look I I
put this on Twitter I'll show it to you
I said look man I am excited I am really
really looking forward to you destroying
the Republican party like nothing can be
more [__] hopped up I mean these are
remember remember these are the people
that they have nothing left
to run on right right they tried to go
after inflation inflation's going down
they tried to go after woke that's a
dying issue as we see right they tried
to go after Joe Biden Hunter Biden and
what are they finding out oh it turns
out that the thing that they knew all
along was that there was no evidence
there was no actual evidence to prove
Joe Biden Hunter Biden did anything
wrong and they found out that their
their informants and the whistleblowers
are gone missing and they're dead then
then we don't actually know if they're
real because we've never seen these
tapes
they have nothing left and so now
they're like well we really gotta go
after the lgbtq community and [__]
attack those beers right it's like well
here's what he's talking about deer
rhinos do you see what conservatives
just did to Bud Light and Target you're
not conservatives you're Nazis okay
over 50 billion in Market drop market
cap went poof which is all [__] yeah
it's all nonsense once they cross the
line what makes you think we won't do
the same to the GOP backstabbers which
what the how in the [__] are you gonna
use Market boycotts against the GOP
backstabbers like you did with bloodline
Target but okay man you do you and
here's what I said I said I'm really
rooting for you to destroy the
Republican Party really I am like this
is what I want you to do this is the
whole point like it's the whole point of
the show is for me to get you to destroy
yourselves like I I want to Handy the
shovel throw you down the rakes or you
just step on these are all things that I
want right but I said but if you're
gonna go with the Bud Light Target
strategy I'm afraid I'll be disappointed
like
dude you didn't destroy Bud Light you
didn't destroy Target there's still
targets everywhere there's still their
stocks up what the [__] are you talking
about man they still got Pride displays
in those stores yeah they're not gonna
shut down any of that no and really
honestly here soon I would imagine and I
don't know but I would imagine that
Target's gonna start changing their
displays here next week or so to have
Patriot stuff because it's going to be
July so they're gonna put Patriots stuff
and American flags in the little they're
gonna be like oh look we won right
you're gonna be like oh man look at that
America we [__] that's that that's
our flag not that good goddamn queer
flag I got rainbow [__] that's what
they're gonna say oh man they [__]
[__] to our demands it's like no it's a
[__] season change you [__] idiot
right but DC Drano Rogan Rogan sounds
like a [__] character that would be
like on some like subpar 12th tier
wrestling out of a bar situation and um
DC Drano and they're like and what do
you do
the swamp and ah we'll get on the top
rope and give you the people's elbow
yeah you can't call it the people's
elbow man it's under it's [__]
trademark dude you can't call that
because it's Savage yeah Randy Savage
man he was killer sorry you can't
have you ever listened have you ever
listened to Randy Savage like do his
like ad-libs and stuff he was a [__]
killer man no he was no he's the best at
it oh [__] yeah he was the best everyone
thinks Hogan was the best [__] no there
was no and they think the Rock's good at
it
learned it from man
I didn't want to watch the show I watch
it for a little bit and then I kind of
turned off what's that uh young Rock I
think they just canceled it I'm actually
but they had three seasons and is it
because it sucked yeah I know it just
wasn't it wasn't actually like the first
season was like oh it's got some
promising you know kind of
uh potential here well but you know
that's how it happens with big movie
stars right yeah I try to sell anything
around them right right and and so
basically in the show you see young Rock
but he's he's surrounded by all of these
key members right Andre the Giant and
all these other people like you see them
and how he grew up with them in various
parts of his life so you see all these
people
like [__] Randy Savage and everyone
else and Hulk Hogan and all these other
people were at different points and they
come in and they you know they're like
oh this is a life lesson that The Rock
learned from this person when he was
five or when he was uh 13 or when he was
22 or whatever it is right
uh Brandon says here I met Randy Savage
a few times the guy was amazing and
smart as [__] that person is realized
here's the thing Randy Savage and if you
like listen to interviews like Hulk
Hogan and him and Hulk Hogan were good
friends for years and then they kind of
had a falling out and then he kind of
before Randy died because I I I can't
remember Randy Savage died but he's he's
dead now but um um Randy like people
would say that we're around Randy during
his wrestling career like the dude that
was on stage I was yelling and screaming
like everyone that's Randy Savage like
he's intense man yeah he's intense he's
extra that's Randy and he really is like
yeah like that's him
what was it what was the tagline yeah
they even had a cami they had like a
little like Easter egg Cameo part of
like slim jim coming in and when when
Randy Savage basically like pitched
himself kind of like a subtle thing and
then then you were like oh and then from
there you know you can imagine they made
this relationship
uh someone says Randy Savage was a
Pioneer he really was like I'm telling
you
um again if you think Hulk Hogan was
good at the trash talk and like uh if
you if you were a fan of professional
wrestling
um of course I was in the 90s like I and
and I I like the WCW at the time and
Randy Randy Savage was at the WCW so was
Hulk Hogan as Hollywood Hogan
um and but if you if you really go back
and look at it like Randy Savage was the
one who set the bar for like yeah when
you're just [__] just going off it
was great but
but again uh to go back to like
WrestleMania in real life because that's
what they're we say this all the time
we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life and that's
really what happens like those fans of
of professional wrestling and that
attitude of loving professional
wrestling even though you you know it's
probably not really real but you want it
to be real and you want to believe that
it might be real or at some level that
these are that's actually the person
that's doing that thing they're actually
jumping and hitting each other and
beating each other up
well the same people right now are doing
that with our politics right yeah and
it's this this story about Joe and
Hunter Biden like they don't actually
believe this [__] they don't actually
know what's real and what's not like
they don't know that the chair isn't
really hurting the person right yeah and
these moves aren't really hurting the
person and and these two people in the
ring are actually you know working
against each other to fool them and they
don't know that Rudy Giuliani Chuck
Grassley Johnson all these [__]
talking heads out there Benny Johnson uh
the daily wire and Fox News oan
newsbacks they're all in coordination
and working against to make them believe
that this shit's real right they have no
idea and they'll suck it up and they'll
believe it because we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and that's the truth that's why we
are going to keep pointing it out here
on the Tony Michaels podcast every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours today was two and a half
hours yeah the week make sure to
subscribe to the YouTube channel you
don't want to miss a single episode
every single weekday you also follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google make sure if you want
to watch it on Facebook make sure you go
at the Tony Michaels on Facebook also
you can see us on the up buyers YouTube
channel just go to the upwire.com you
can type in the up wire on YouTube
search it boom you'll find it
and make sure you follow us on Twitch
it's free to follow us on Twitch go to
twitch.tv Tony Michaels we got great
support a great chat over there on
Twitch go follow us use your Prime
account to subscribe to our Twitch
account and it gives us free monetary
support it's kind of cool also Tony Tony
big time for you for you for people like
yourself yes this weekend Father's Day
it is Father's day it is thank you it is
Father's Day this weekend so all the
dads out there everyone who has who who
has a dad to go love them and hug them
and you know maybe drink queer beer with
him go do that this weekend have a great
Father's Day weekend I want to thank all
the moderators um that are in the chat
thanks again to miss love speak for uh
bringing out the story with Tommy
tuberville we're glad we put him on the
bonehead of the week
uh to everyone out there that helps us
on the show including you the audience
who helps us by coming here every single
weekday watching all two hours We
Appreciate You Happy Father's Day this
weekend don't do anything I wouldn't do
have a great weekend safe weekend we'll
see you same time same place on Monday
we got a great guest on Monday oh yeah
so we'll see you then Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them
[Music]
thank you
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
that's asked about K-pop boy bands or
whatever the [__] box is you want to
talk about something that goddamn
matters let's [__] talk about how
Trump and his ass lickers are trying to
destroy this country while they sit on
their fat [__] asses eating Big Macs
and jerking off to Fox News that's what
we should be talking about not some
[__] Korean Babyface singers or
whatever the [__] they are and you know
why Trump loves fast food so much
it's because he can shove it down his
throat without having to use those
idiotic Little Fingers of his
[Music]